Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und hier ist die Ausgabe siebenundsechzig.
Und es ist Freitag und es ist nicht irgendein Freitag, es ist der Karfreitag,
Wir feiern und tanzen hier äh ausführlich. Ähm der zweite April zwanzig einundzwanzig. Ja und äh das Freitag ist, ist Corona Wiekli. Ich sage hallo zu Pavel.
Das ist sie wieder die Sendung, die äh jede Woche versucht, für euch die,
Zahlen und Geschehnisse und Entwicklung rund um die Korona Krise ein wenig einzusortieren.
Ja und letzte Mal sind wir ja so ein bisschen außer Spur gegangen, ne? Habe ich so den Eindruck. Kann man das so umschreiben?
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, was zum Mainzer bin, dann bist du aus der Spur äh gegan.
Das kann gut sein.
Etwas vorsichtiger, wenn du jetzt auf die Fusion anspielst.
Nee, darauf spüle ich nicht an, sondern ich meine die Einschätzung der äh allgemeinen Situation und wie wir da vor allem das Verhalten der Politik so äh bewerten.
Du meinst, dass wir etwas emotionaler waren als äh sonst, ja, ja. Ja, leider, da stimme ich äh voll und ganz mit dir überein.
Und ähm tja.
Zu meiner Überraschung scheint sich das dann irgendwie auch sofort ausgewirkt zu haben. Ich glaube ein Tag später, also Samstag kam die Sendung raus und am Sonntag.
Der letzten Woche, also letzten Sonntag waren Angela Merkel bei Anne Will in dieser Quatschsendung.
Ich gucke mir ja Fernsehen normalerweise nicht an und schon gar nicht diese Talk-Sendung, die da seit einem Jahr laufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da irgendwas verpasse oder.
Ja vielleicht schon so ein bisschen aber äh ja die meisten davon sind
auch tatsächlich schwer zu ertragen
So die bleiben halt sehr an der Oberfläche. Ich meine, sie helfen dabei so ein bisschen einzuordnen so paar Rösse und so ein paar Reiter und äh wohin die
unterwegs sind, das kriegt man dann relativ kompak.
Serviert, aber ja es fehlt die Tiefe, aber wenn denn schon mal die Kanzlerin äh so,
sich in der Prime Time hinsetzt und ja ähm,
in die Kamera redet alleine für ja über eine fast 'ne Stunde glaub ich.
Stunde war's äh ja.
Äh so, dass äh ja, dass es dann schon interessant vor allen Dingen ähm sowas interessan
zwischen den Zeilen zu lesen, natürlich zu sehen, wie formuliert sie Dinge, wie reagiert sie auf bestimmte Fragen und so und insofern,
war das dann schon ein Highlight, fand ich.
Ja, das habe ich mir dann auch im Nachgang dann auch nochmal angehört. Gibt's ja auch als Podcast, muss man diese ganze.
Da nicht äh äh geben und es ist ja auch dann auch immer so die Sondernummer, dass sie halt nicht mehrere Schreihälser haben, sondern einfach sie nur alleine. Und das war ja dann schon fast so ein bisschen so eine Regierungserklärung.
Die sie da abgelassen hat und das war schon ziemlich bemerkenswert, weil,
Weil sie ja irgendwie ganz ordentlich ausgeteilt hat unter anderem so an ihren neuen Parteivorsitzenden, dem sie ja dann so auf zweite Nachfrage auch klar attestiert hat, dass er eigentlich daneben liegt.
Ja, also ich also für mich war das deswegen auch so eine bewegte Woche, weil was man ja,
in der letzten Sendung live mitverfolgen konnte, war, wie mir so ein bisschen Synchronleuchter aufging
dass nämlich einige der CDU-Ministerpräsidenten eigentlich Korona Leugner sind, ja? Also zumindest
Corona verharmloser und halt denken, wie äh viele Koronaleugner so indem sie,
denken, es geht halt alles von alleine weg und man müsste nichts tun und der Lokdown ist ist schlimmer als die Infektion und so diese ganzen Dinge, die man normalerweise eigentlich nur von Querdenkern hört.
Stecken eben auch in den Köpfen von Ministerpräsidenten und das war also diese ungeheuerliche Gedanke, wollte mir einfach bis,
dahin nicht kommen so und als wir dann in der letzten Sendung nach den Einspielern von dir so der Kronleuchter aufging.
Da habe ich halt geguckt, ist aber wie viel ist denn da dran? Und in dem Moment plötzlich, wo meine Augen geöffnet waren
und ich das auch thematisiert habe, kam dann erstmal mehrere Hinweise so zum Beispiel von denen der Laschet sich so alles beraten lässt, ja, wie der so in der ganzen auch im christlichen, fundamentalismusecke und äh
Treibungskritiker, Ecke und so,
nahe steht und dass das eigentlich sich ja einige der CDU-Ministerpräsidenten offenbar
auch ein Beispiel an amerikanischen äh republikanischen Gouverneuren nehmen gerade, die sagen es Corona ist vorbei, wir machen jetzt Aufwärmen da keinen Bock mehr äh drauf und was der Bund sagt, interessiert uns nicht.
So und dann kam's halt auch äh so wie ich natürlich speziell,
mir Merkel angehört wie sehen das das Verhältnis mit,
Laschet zum Beispiel darstellt mit dem Corona Leugner Laschet. So, schätzt sie das auch so ein und hm ähm.
Also sie sagte dann ja, manche Ministerpräsidenten äh scheinen nicht ganz illusionsfrei
zu sein und für mich ist so der Begriff nicht ganz illusionsfrei, mal sagen, ja okay, vielleicht keine Corona Leugner, sondern Corona, Illusioniere
Aber das ist dann irgendwie doch schon für mich ein bisschen zu apologetisch, äh dass sagen na ja, die haben sich jetzt so ein bisschen von der Hoffnung hinreißen lassen
ja. Nee, ist nicht und ja, dann hast du ja die schöne Ansage gemacht. Ja, jetzt ist, jetzt ist Schluss, ab jetzt
äh erzählt, was ihr wollt. Äh es gibt jetzt keine Entschuldigung, jetzt zählen, um nur noch Ergebnisse. So.
Das sind auch nochmal auf Twitter so mit dem mit dem Spruch, jetzt ist Hefte raus, Klassenarbeit und,
ich meine, kaum haben wir das im Podcast formuliert mit zarrerweise setzt sich dann die Kanzlerin zwei Tage später ins Fernsehen und macht genau diese Ansage an die Ministerpräsidenten
Mich interessiert euer Gequatsche jetzt nicht mehr
die Zahlen müssen runter. Vorher brauchen wir gar nicht mehr zu reden, ja? Es ist so das fand ich dann doch sehr, sehr,
bemerkenswert, also komisches Universum äh haben wir hier. Vielleicht hört ja irgendjemand heimlich unseren Pot,
äh äh mit äh oder so in einflussreicher Position und wir ähm,
ohne es zu wissen, manipulieren wir hier äh so die große Politik mal eben mit. Ja, ich weiß, das ist äh äh absurd, aber mir ist sowas tatsächlich
mehrmals unterlaufen in in meinem Leben, dass ich mich gewundert habe,
warum bestimmte Dinge passieren? Ähm so äh und ich hinterher zwanzig Jahre hinterher von den Akteuren äh dann erfahren habe, ja, dass sie deswegen passiert sind, weil sie gesehen haben, was ich,
gemacht und gesagt und getan habe und darauf reagiert haben so. Ja? Und äh.
Das war jetzt im Bereich Softwareentwicklung und so und ja großes amerikanisches Unternehmen
aber ja manchmal nehmen Informationen halt merkwürdige Wege, aber ich würde das trotzdem erstmal,
vielleicht nicht ganz als Koinzidenz, sondern einfach eine verbreitete Stimmungslage so.
Wir können natürlich auch gerne einfach weiter wünsch dir was spielen hier äh und dann gucken wir mal, was davon ankommt.
Auf jeden Fall ähm kann man sagen, der Auftritt von Merkel war äh bemerkenswert. Ähm allerdings am Ende auch.
Genauso luftleer, weil sie ja auch nur müde Androhungen gemacht hat. Das ging dann halt schon so weit, dass sie.
Wenn ich das richtig interpretiere in den Raum gestellt hat, dass wenn die Ministerpräsidenten nicht mehr für die Umsetzung des beschlossenen tun, dass dann,
das Infektionsschutzgesetz angepasst werden muss. Das hat sie ja auch glaube ich konkret benannt und was das eigentlich bedeutet, heißt.
Macht von den Ländern zum Bund schieben. Um dann Dinge durchsetzen zu können, die derzeit von den Ländern umgesetzt werden müssen.
Ja und Söder ist er dann gleich, als hätten sie's abgesprochen in den,
Tagesthemen nach der Anne Will Sendung glaube ich gleich zur Seite gesprungen und hat gesagt jo, jawohl, was die Kanzlerin sagt ist richtig und äh
brachte dann auch noch den bemerkenswerten Satz so in den Tagesthemen auch zur Prime Time. Mein man macht sich das nicht klar, wenn man.
So äh in so einer Fernsehinterviewsituation in einem dieser
Prime Formate ist, wie wenig Sekunden man eigentlich hat, um seine Message loszuwerden, wie komprimiert und kompakt man dort reden muss, nicht so ausschweifend wie wir hier im Podcast, äh sondern das muss halt ja
hundert, das ist hundertfach komprimiert und äh
und dabei schaffte er es aber dann zu erwähnen, trotz dieser Zeitknappheit, dass halt offenbar manche Ministerpräsidenten ihre Korona-Information aus alternativen Quellen beziehen
So, also äh das war dann äh nochmal so eine äh so eine Bestätigung äh eigentlich äh wie,
die die Situation da aussieht und ausgesehen hat, wobei man sagen muss, auch nicht alle mindestens nicht alle CDU-Ministerpräsidenten sind so, da gibt es doch äh äh sehr viele,
Unterschiede, ja und was Merkel, also was mich denn noch wirklich wirklich beeindruckt hat, wie.
Wie gut Angela Merkel informiert war über,
die ganzen Fakten und Zahlen und Einschätzungen und so. Die könnte hier auch, wenn ich mal ausfalle, könnte Angela Merkel sofort übernehmen hier.
Oha.
Die na gut, vielleicht ist sie nicht im Detail so tief in allen Zahlen drin, aber generell so äh ja
dass das auch mit der Einschätzung der Tests und so, wozu die gut sind und
wo nicht im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen Politikern, da scheidet sich so ein bisschen die Spreu vom Weizen des die einen mehr so, aber ja, wir haben ja jetzt die Tests und Angela Merkel, ja, aber die Tests
sind zwar okay, aber sie taugen halt nicht um,
wirklich zu senken, wenn man gleichzeitig öffnet, aber da erzählen wir später noch drüber, nee. Und also Angela Merkel, also die Wissenschaftlerin, Angela Merkel, hm,
war perfekt im Thema Faktensicher so und dann irgendwann als.
Anne Will nachfragt ja, was ist denn jetzt äh mit harten Blockdown und so
dann äh übernahm plötzlich die Politikerin Angela Merkel äh wieder und
schob die Wissenschaftlerin komplett beiseite und meinte naja aber die Schulen und die Firmen müssen ja schon aufbleiben, ja? Und
Das war wirklich faszinierend zu beobachten, wie selbst bei äh jemandem, äh wie der Bundeskanzlerin, die ja eigentlich eher so als
ja die harte Maßnahmen befürworterin dann doch wenn's drauf ankommt die Politikerin,
wird und wenn das schon bei der Kanzlerin so ist, äh wie viel Hoffnung haben wir denn da äh noch, wenn man sich die ganze Ministerpräsidentensiege anschaut.
Ja, das war alles ganz unterhaltsam, aber dann äh passierte halt vor allem erstmal wieder nichts.
Auch zu was auch total zu erwarten war nach dem Abend, weil was sich nämlich auch bestätigt hat, ist äh.
Was dadurch schien ist, Merkels
größte Stärke und gleichzeitig ihre größte Schwäche, nämlich ihre Fähigkeit oder ihr Hang oder ihre Neigung zum Kompromiss,
so sie ist einfach der wandelnde Kompromiss so weil sie verkörpert den Kompromiss wie niemand anderer und deswegen war halt schon auch völlig klar.
Das mit schnell, dass so eher nichts wird, aber sie hat halt auf jeden Fall Druck aufgebaut.
Das äh kann man wohl wohl wohl feststellen und ich würde das auch so interpretieren, dass sie das Volk
zur Hilfe gerufen hat gegen die Ministerpräsidenten, das so. Wir haben die Öffentlichkeit jetzt Druck machen soll, dass die Ministerpräsidenten.
Jetzt mal.
Ja, da bin ich mir nicht ganz so sicher. Also ich habe auch so ein paar Analysen gelesen, die eigentlich sagen, ja, das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen eine politische Message gewesen, weil sie ja jetzt so das Volk auch nicht wirklich.
Also sie hat ja jetzt nicht.
Zur Attacke geblasen. Also, man kann immer sagen, für ihre Verhältnisse schon, aber damit sich dieses träge äh Volk auch bewegt, in irgendeine Richtung, da musst du, glaube ich, schon ein bisschen lauter ins Horn tuten.
Ja, es ist, ich meine, es ist Wahljahr so, super Wahljahr. Ähm.
Und ja äh und.
Die ganze Situation ist natürlich schon dramatisch, hm so mit dem Einbruch jetzt auf fünfundzwanzig Prozent. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich die CDU in Umfragen schon wieder begonnen hat, zu erholen oder wie weit das noch runtergeht.
Aber sie hat mal eben auch in diesem äh ja, in diesem Interview den.
Bisher vermutlich von der CDU favorisierten Kanzlerkandidaten abgeschossen. So dass es ist natürlich auch,
ja, also es war nicht mal eben nur so, hm, wir müssen mal reden oder so, sondern nee, das war so knallhart reingrätscht in das Ding und dann,
mal eben, ja, den äh äh Laschet demoliert, so.
Auf jeden Fall hat sie das. Also das war schon relativ klar und ich denke sie äh.
Sie wird sich natürlich niemals dazu äußern, aber das ist halt schon so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Prepping für für Söder, der wahrscheinlich der einzige ist, den sie derzeit irgendwas zutraut und leider feststellen muss, dass in ihrer eigenen CDU niemand da ist, der irgendwie.
Einfach irgendwie irgendwas auf dem Kasten hat, oder? Also.
Ja, der Söder das Wasser reichen kann und ich meine, es ist auch ja
es ist einfach, ich meine, Laschet ist ein zweitklassiger Provinzpolitiker, ja, der irgendwie durch das so ist mit den politischen Wirren. Ich meine, ich bin auch
unverhofft irgendwann mal in ein Landesparlament gespült worden so und so ist Laschet halt durch eine Verquickung unglücklicher Umstände
ja Ministerpräsident geworden des größten deutschen Bundeslandes, obwohl er dafür eigentlich gar nicht qualifiziert ist.
Ja? Und jetzt und deswegen dann auch noch auf dem Weg zum Bundeskanzler äh Amt war bis ja bis letzten Sonntag.
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall sehr unklug. Wie er da vorgegangen ist. Na ja.
Ja und dann auch dann der Trotz äh sozusagen dann, wenn man wie das zu erwarten war, war er dann erstmal jetzt trotzig und ja inzwischen weiß ich nicht, ob äh ich habe,
da Schadensbegrenzung noch möglich ist. Ich glaube nicht.
Er hat angekündigt, dass er am Wochenende, also jetzt, während wir hier sprechen, nachdenken will.
Oh
Da weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich das als Drogen auffassen soll.
Man das irgendwie drunter abspeichern sollte. Keine Ahnung, ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob er wenn er danach gedacht hat, ob er uns mitteilt, ob er ob er auf irgendwas gekommen ist.
Ja ja aber.
Das könnte natürlich passieren.
Ja, aber.
Mein Nachdenken ist jetzt vielleicht kein verkehrter Ansatz so, aber ja hm kommt finde grade ein bisschen spät so nach,
einem Japanimi mal zu Beginn nachzudenken.
Ja. Na gut.
Aber besser später als nie, aber wir werden sehen. Wir werden sehen, aber.
Andere tun das auf jeden Fall und ähm man hat schon das Gefühl, es braut sich jetzt langsam was zusammen.
Gerade äh kurz, ich glaube kurz bevor wir hier aufgenommen haben, kam noch irgendwie ein Video raus von der Quarksredaktion,
ehemals Quarks und Co. Ja, da haben wir mittlerweile eine Menge neuer Leute äh Raum gefunden, was ich auch ganz gut finde und ist ja eine.
Sehr,
honorige Wissenschaftssendungen muss man mal sagen, also was bei Quark so in den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten rausgekommen ist, das das kann sich eigentlich immer sehen lassen, soweit ich das verfolgt habe und bewerten kann,
Und sie haben sich natürlich auch schon im ganzen letzten Jahr äh regelmäßig zu Corona äh natürlich gemeldet und viel Erklärbärkram äh gemacht und auch immer wieder äh an Prognosen teilgenommen
Und jetzt haben sie ein Video veröffentlicht, dass sie selbst als Journalistischen Kommentar deklariert haben,
sehr ungewöhnlich, zwölf Minuten und es ist im Prinzip ja das Äquivalent zu einer.
Ja zu einer zu wirklich einer watschenden Ohrfeige der der Politik gegenüber. Also sie wirklich dann.
Haarklein, so wie wir das ja hier eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit machen. Immer wieder äh durchsitziert haben, was eigentlich so im letzten Jahr alles so passiert ist, was alles so vorhergesagt wurde, was dann alles nicht getan wurde,
ja? Und so weiter, bis Stand letzter Woche wieder nichts passiert ist und die sind,
richtig also den Platz der Kragen. Ich lese mal den Text vor, den sie unter dieses Video gepackt haben.
Ja so ein bisschen so eine Zusammenfassung ist und das ähm.
Trifft's glaube ich ganz gut. Sie schreiben. Corona ist uns nun schon seit über einem Jahr fester Bestandteil.
Unseres Alltags und damit auch zwangsläufig Teil der deutschen Politik Bund und Länder tagen regelmäßig um neue Maßnahmen zu beschließen.
Oder auch wieder zu revidieren. Beraten zur Seite stehen ihnen dabei zahlreiche Wissenschaftlerinnen, Epidemiologinnen,
aber ein Großteil der politischen Entscheidungstragenden ignoriert zunehmend die Warnung der Expertinnen. Viele bei uns in der Redaktion macht das wütend,
wütend haben sie geschrieben,
Weiter. Die Korona Politik ist mit Sicherheit nicht immer leicht. Zu Beginn war nicht ganz klar, wie sich das Virus entwickeln und die Pandemie verlaufen wird. Dennoch forschen, recherchieren und beraten, Wissenschaftlerin seit Anfang an, um neue Erkenntnisse über Corona zu erlangen,
die von der Politik aufgefasst und genutzt werden sollten. Aber ist das auch wirklich passiert? Wir finden nicht.
Es gab etliche Prognosen zu Corona und zum Verlauf dieser Pandemie und sie waren ziemlich akkurat, wenn man auf das Jahr zurückblickt. Dennoch hat die Politik regelmäßig Warnungen von Wissenschaftlerinnen zu einer zweiten,
und einer dritten Welle ignoriert und viel zu langsam und schwach reagiert.
All das soll laut der Politik ein Kompromiss zwischen Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft sein, doch das ist faktisch falsch. Je mehr die Wissenschaft ignoriert wird, desto länger hängen wir in Logdownlights oder weiteren Koronawellen fest.
Das Café von nebenan wäre sicher froh über einen harten und schnellen Lokdown, um danach wieder richtig öffnen zu können, anstelle von Halbgaren Entscheidungen und immer wieder Schließungen seit Oktober.
Wissenschaft und ihre Erkenntnisse sind wichtig für die Politik, während Corona und die Politik im Allgemeinen.
Macht uns wütend und traurig, dass wissenschaftlich fundierte Erkenntnisse hinsichtlich Corunna im Moment eher als Eventualität gesehen und häufig komplett ignoriert werden.
Also so klingt jemand, der äh vollkommen am Ende der Weisheit äh äh ist und.
Einfach sprachlos da steht und sagt was Erlaube Politik.
Ja ich meine wir hatten ja auch hier unseren ähm Tiefpunkt, sage ich mal, unseren emotionalen Tiefpunkt, glaube ich, beide,
verkündet zu meiner war eine Woche früher als deiner, wie geht's dir eigentlich jetzt so emotional.
Mit der Gesamtsituation so wie es äh weil sie es sozusagen ja zwischen ich sage mal äh äh Resignation und äh Verzweiflung und Hoffnung, wo wo ähm.
Bewegst du dich gerade.
Na ja, also ich meine ich hätte das glaube ich so wie wie ich das die ganze Zeit händel. Ich gehe immer vom vom schlimmsten aus und freue mich dann äh immer, wenn's ein bisschen besser wird.
Nur wenn dann eben auch noch meine schlimmsten Annahmen unterboten werden, dann werde ich halt ein bisschen zickig.
Also das ging mir jetzt schon so mit den Impfungen so ein bisschen. Das hat einfach nicht diesen Ruck geliefert, von dem ich ausgegangen bin, dass diesen das Liefern.
Könnte den sicherlich auch geliefert hätte, wenn es irgendwie ordentlich angegangen wäre.
War schwierig für uns vorherzusagen, glaube ich, wie das laufen könnte, aber ich dachte, wenn dann quasi Hands Orden praktische Arbeit von Leuten, die das verstehen, getan wird, dann wird das schon irgendwie gehen, nur, dass eben diese
ganze Impflieferungsgeschichte so schwierig sein würde. Nun, aber es ist halt auch dieses.
Man weiß, wie soll ich sagen.
Klar, die Politik ist die Politik und diese Öffentlichkeit ist die Öffentlichkeit, ne? Die Frage ist, wie sehr wird das von der Gesellschaft noch getragen und geduldet? Und man muss halt auch sagen, äh aus welchen Gründen auch immer, die Gesellschaft hat's auch alles noch nicht so richtig verstanden
Jetzt kann man natürlich lange drüber debattieren, wessen Aufklärungs ähm Verantwortung,
hier jetzt greifen müsste, da kann man sicherlich auch gleich wieder auf diese Politik zeigen, aber am Ende nehme ich halt dann doch uns alle eigentlich ins Gebiet
das ist eigentlich so, wie ich's bisher auch immer gemacht habe, weil ich immer nicht so richtig viel Sinn darin gesehen habe, einzelne herauszupicken, weil,
Die gewisse Sache ist so komplex und so miteinander verwoben. Das ist aber schwierig, es irgendwas runterzubrechen auf,
dass es passiert, weil X das und das getan oder nicht getan hat. Im Einzelfall klar,
Ne, kann man kann man sowas schon mal heranziehen, aber insgesamt,
sehe ich's halt als ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Versagen. Also da da funktioniert irgendein,
Selbstschutzmechanismus in dieser Gesellschaft nicht ausreichend. Wir sind kollektiv, nicht nicht in der Lage das Richtige herbeizuführen. Ja, auch die Politiker sind wir.
Das ist nicht irgendwie eine fremde Macht, die jetzt gerade irgendwie,
um die Ecke gekommen ist und uns irgendwie die Pistole auf die Brust gesetzt hat, sondern das das die haben wir vorher gewählt, die haben wir in diese Position gebracht und sind unsere äh Reaktionen oder nicht Reaktionen, die letzten Endes auch
ihr Grundverhalten mit ähm führ,
damit will ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, wir wir sind ja jetzt auch alle irgendwie schuld, damit ist keiner schuld. Natürlich gibt es hier schon Versäumnisse, nur die müssen dann eben auch einfach mal langsamer behoben werden.
Also wie geht's mir damit? Es ist so ein Überlebenstrieb, dass ich äh im auch immer die Ist-Situation für mich akzeptiere.
Also alles andere macht einen ja wahnsinnig, ne.
Ja nicht äh trotzdem wie gesagt äh gibt's dann äh sozusagen hat man schon seine Höhen und äh Tiefen und wenn man bei mir jetzt gut das das schöne warme Wetter der der letzten Tage, auch wenn ich.
Nur von von drinnen genossen habe, hm weil ich.
Anderes zu tun hatte. Ähm ja, das wirkt aber dann trotzdem so stimmungsaufhellend und äh zumindest der Teil so mit dem der dunkle, kalte Winter, der, der ja auch äh immer.
Eher nicht so lustig ist in in Deutschland und speziell eben Berlin heißt es ja immer okay, wer wer einmal in Berlin es schafft einen Winter äh durchzuhalten und nicht nicht abhaut, der bleibt halt für immer. Hm.
Aber.
Ja ähm nee äh ja äh meine ich schöpfe gerade, hoffe so ein bisschen Hoffnung daraus, dass die Zahlen bisher.
Ganz so schnell ansteigen wie befürchtet oder wie es hätte sein können. Also da ist bisschen.
Verzögerung drin äh gerade, die mir Hoffnung macht, die uns zumindest Zeit gibt oder.
Nicht wirklich Zeit gibt, aber sage ich mal, die Auswirkungen dessen, dass die Politik,
mal wieder Zeit braucht um zu tun, was sie weiß, dass eigentlich getan werden müsste und,
Es sieht ja so aus, dass so jetzt ein Land nach dem anderen da irgendwie umkippt und auch die öffentliche Meinung jetzt wieder gerade kippt und äh jetzt die Leute vielleicht
gerade auch ein bisschen Kraft und Energie wieder getankt haben und äh ja alles nur so
einen Hauch davon, also es ist jetzt nicht, nicht, dass es jemand falsch versteht und.
Es wäre jetzt alles vorbei. Interessanterweise ist es jetzt ziemlich genau.
Auf den Tag ein Jahr her, wenn ich das richtig sehe, dass wir auf dem Höhepunkt der ersten Welle waren,
und jetzt kann man natürlich auch ganz genau tracken vor einem Jahr begann es begannen die Zahlen jetzt zu sink.
Und man da jetzt eben ja die Trends von vor einem Jahr über die Trends, über die aktuellen Trends legen und hat dann einen ganz guten Maßstab äh in den nächsten Wochen,
der auch die Frage jetzt der Saisonalität zum Beispiel einzuordnen hilft, weil wir ja damals jetzt auch keine.
Also ja es läuft halt quasi synchron und wenn's,
so ist wie viele sich das wünschen, nämlich dass das von alleine weggeht, wenn der Sommer kommt, dann müsste sich das jetzt langsam,
bemerkbar machen, dann dürfte es eigentlich dürften die Neuinfektion jetzt nur noch abwärts gehen. Was nicht zu erwarten ist.
Ne, also so da damit rechne ich jetzt auch nicht. Was mich eigentlich am meisten stört ist, dass dieses Hinauszögern, was wir jetzt erleben in diesem Moment gerade.
Frisst sich einfach in diesen Sommer rein und und nimmt, ich meine, jetzt hast du es gerade gesagt, das schöne Wetter kommt.
Wie ungeil wird das, wenn dann sozusagen auch noch so dieser Hoffnungsschimmer auch noch vollkommen Durchschließungen äh überschattet wird? Und dann wird er auch nochmal schlechter funktionieren in Deutschland. Das ist halt das andere.
Alles raus. Also man kann fast ja sagen, jeder Tag wo jetzt nichts passiert sind hinten raus wahrscheinlich nicht nur zwei Tage, sondern irgendwie drei Tage und gefühlte vier Tage.
Einfach noch hinten dran gehängt werden, wo es einfach nicht so ist, wie wir es gerne wollen.
Na ja, also wir können da jetzt lange äh hin und her reden, lassen sie es mal lieber auf die Situation schauen, wie sie jetzt sich aus den Zahlenmaterialen äh konkret ableiten lässt.
Du hast ja ein paar
Fortschritte erzielt bei deiner Tabelle. Wir können jetzt etwas tiefer schauen und etwas ähm besser schauen und äh dementsprechend gibt's jetzt auch leicht geänderte Grafiken
im den Shownote zu dieser Sendung, da könnt ihr,
immer nachschauen, da sind so die wichtigsten Grafiken, die wir jetzt hier in den Zahlen teilen, äh in der Regel einfach mit drin zu eurer Referenz. Ja.
Sag doch mal.
Ja, ich hoffe, äh auch erstmal, ob das äh diese Variante ich auch bald.
Öffentlich stellen kann, die ist halt ganz frisch heute früh fertig geworden oder zumindest soweit fertig geworden, dass man sie jetzt.
Als ich sie zur Produktion von Bildern benutzen kann, aber es ist noch nicht so weit, dass ich's dir jetzt einfach so rausstellen kann. Dazu ist es halt noch zu zu unsauber,
alles und zu zu unschön, aber ähm ja was es halt ermöglicht ist,
dann in der Tabelle jetzt zeilen und Spalten anzuklicken und dann
diese im zeitlichen Verlauf zu sehen so in einer in einem kombinierten Grafen, in dem man dann auch schön rumzoomen kann und,
sich halt dann ja alle möglichen Dinge dann koordinieren äh kann. Plus äh dass es dort jetzt die Tabelle nochmal breiter geworden
ist äh und Daten eben nach Altersgruppen.
Auch noch mit drin sind und die es jetzt aber auch so breit, dass ich das mittlerweile für nicht wirklich zumutbar halte.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine super Ausrede, wenn man schon immer mal überlegt hat, sich einen neun vierzig Zoll Monitor zu kaufen.
Ja. Genau.
Dafür ist es wirklich perfekt.
Ja und am besten irgendwas genauso im mit dem Seitenverhältnis von vierzig zu eins oder so ähm oder zwei äh zwei nebeneinander äh nee, nicht vierzig zu eins, aber äh ja.
Wir suchen auf jeden Fall noch nach nach Lösungen, dass etwas kompakter und handhabbarer äh zu machen.
Ja, so.
Sagt denn jetzt sozusagen das Orakel.
Jahr ein wichtiges Ding äh war jetzt die Frage für mich aktuell, wie sieht's denn.
Sehen wir möglicherweise schon eine Trendwende, weil die BZ vermeldete heute nur völlig,
ohne Kommentar in Berlin die Zahlen und die Institenz, die sieben Tage Institanz in Berlin ist gesunken.
So und so äh und die die Frage war jetzt.
Ist das jetzt die Trendwende.
Und was bedeutet das äh und warum ist der RW nicht unter eins, wenn die Institz gesunken ist.
Und äh gut, es gibt Ehrwerte, die jetzt unter eins wären, tatsächlich für Berlin,
aber im Vergleich, im Wochenvergleich und das ist der einzig robuste Vergleich, den man machen kann, steigen die Zahlen immer noch. Auch wenn tatsächlich in Berlin,
der sieben Tagesschnitt tatsächlich ganz leicht gesunken ist. Aber.
'ne Trendwende ist das noch nicht so. Das war ist tatsächlich,
Ja, wie gesagt, der RWT gesunken und auch die Durchschnittswertgesunken, aber der Erwert,
im Wochenvergleich ist noch immer über eins und vor allen Dingen, wenn man sich dann den Grafen betrachtet, wie um wie viel die Zahlen in.
Wochenrhythmus schwanken. Das ist nämlich äh ja im Moment.
Schwanken die zwischen zehntausendneun.
Fällen und fünfundzwanzigtausend neuen Fällen am Tag und.
Bei so starken Schwankungen
wenn es irgendwie Feiertage oder Ferien gibt,
dann kommt dieser Rhythmus halt ein ganz klein bisschen aus dem Tritt. Das kann man sehen und schon,
werden die Zahlen äh halt ein bisschen,
eckig und kantig und kurvig. So, das heißt wahrscheinlich selbst dieser leichte Rückgang, äh den wir gerade sehen könnte.
Mit Ostern äh zusammenhängen, aber er ist.
Vermutlich trotzdem zu einem Teil real und das.
Wiederum merkt man, wenn man sich jetzt nach Altersgruppen anschaut, wie hat sich das denn jetzt in der letzten Woche oder in äh ja.
Und gerade in den in den letzten Tagen entwickelt und.
Dann stellt man zwei Dinge fest und das da haben.
Hinterher auch nochmal ein bisschen mehr drauf drauf kommen, aber wir hatten ja schon erwähnt, dass diese dritte Welle jetzt ihren Ausgangspunkt.
Bei den Kindern genommen hat. Und man kann sogar differenzieren anhand der Kurven, ob,
in einem Land, das jetzt über die Kitas gegangen ist oder ob das über die Schulen gegangen ist oder über Kitas und Schulen im gleichen Maße, aber,
die Kurven selbst sind halt sehr beeindruckend und auch der Zeitpunkt, also in Berlin ist es so.
Da ging's Ende Februar los, also Mitte, Ende Februar fing halt,
Kinder und Jugendlichen an äh dort, die Institz steil nach oben zu gehen und war jetzt bevor.
Die Osterferien begonnen haben,
hat die Altersgruppe null bis vier Jahre die höchste Institz von allen Altersgruppen mit zweihundert,
fünfundzwanzig in Berlin erreicht im Piek und die Altersgruppe fünf bis vierzehn so mit ungefähr ah wenn man jetzt äh so ja mit ungefähr zweihundert.
Zwanzig dem nicht nahe gestanden und dann, also es hat sich sagen die Institenzen haben sich halt umgekehrt äh fast bei der während wir in der letzten Welle.
Die Institutionen bei den alten Hoch und bei den Jungen unten war sieht's jetzt anders aus, aber.
Und deswegen erwähne ich das,
so seit eben jetzt Ferien sind, sieht man bei den Kindern und Jugendlichen einen,
deutlichen Abfall äh wieder. Es ist jetzt zwar also um ungefähr ja sind das vierzig, vierzig pro hunderttausend
weniger in diesen beiden Altersklassen. Das heißt, man kann an diesen äh Graphen eigentlich sehr, sehr schön,
sehen, was sich gerade abspielt.
Und das kann man halt dann für jedes Bundesland machen und ich habe das auch, weil ich die Landsendung.
Gestern geschaut habe, habe ich dann während ich das getan habe, mal versucht, so einen paar.
Kurven für die Länder.
Also Sachsen habe ich mir dann beispielsweise angeschaut, war natürlich dort dort auch, dass das Thema war und ja in Sachsen.
Sind's definitiv nicht die Kitas äh gewesen, beziehungsweise die Kitas haben halt auch beigetragen
Aber da waren's ganz klar die Schulöffnungen,
Und da sehen wir auch jetzt aber seit zwei Wochen in der Altersgruppe von fünf bis vierzehn einen Rückgang, die zu dem Zeitpunkt aber auch Rekordhalter. Ja und so kann man dann.
Sehr schön die einzelnen Länder durchgehen und sich die Folgen anschauen, die halt die Politik dort in den verschiedenen.
Altersgruppen ja gebracht hat. Thüringen interessanterweise in Thüringen sieht's,
bisschen anders aus, da waren's zwar auch anfänglich.
Ja, also ich meine, das ist ein etwas andere Skalierung, sehe ich gerade ja ne in in Thüringen, dass,
da waren's auch die Schulen beziehungsweise da waren die Kitas am stärksten, die Treiber, da waren die Kitas stärker als die als die Schulen und.
Sind aber jetzt äh wieder von den älteren.
Überholt worden, also da sind es jetzt sind jetzt die achtzig plus und die sechzig bis neunundsiebzig ziehen ganz gut an, ja.
Beziehungsweise ne, in Thüringen ist es auch die arbeitstätige Bevölkerung, die gerade so die höchsten Institenzen hat mit um die dreihundertfünfzig. Also.
Im Prinzip gut die Altersgruppe von fünfzehn bis ein Altersgruppen von fünfzehn bis neunundfünfzig treiben in Thüringen, gerade die Pandemie,
Ja dann,
Mama Schleswig-Holstein, was ja eher so was hätte zahlen Land ist und da bei der Kubiki in der Sendung, deswegen habe ich mir das.
Angeschaut und.
Wie fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig äh hat, da dominiert, da sind die tatsächlich die Kinder, die Kitas und die Schulen nicht ganz so krass gewesen, aber,
in den letzten zwei Wochen haben sich dann.
Auch die Schulen so rauskristallisiert als Altersgruppe.
Fünf bis vierzehn ist jetzt dort die dominante mit der mit der höchsten Inzidenz und hat die äh knapp gefolgt von fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig. So, das ist halt,
ja, dann Schleswig-Holstein. So und ähm ja als letztes dann vielleicht noch nach Hamburg, das ist halt.
Berlin, da ist auch fünf bis neun fünf bis vierzehn Grad Rekordhalter und die.
Kitas und die Schulen sind dort aber mehr oder weniger synchron,
gelaufen als als Hauptinstitenzort, aber irgendwann haben sich die Schulen auch durchgesetzt gegenüber den den Kitas oder gegenüber den Kindern im Kita-Alter, ja.
Hand, oder?
Ja, sehr interessant. Grundsätzlich, um's vielleicht mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, äh wenn ich's richtig rausgehört habe, man kann sagen
seit einem Monat etwas mehr in einem Monat, also seitdem die fallenden Zahlen in Deutschland erst ein Plateau gebildet haben und dann wieder,
Nach oben ging, nachdem sozusagen die zweite Welle vorzeitig als beendet erklärt wurde und dann nahtlos in die dritte Welle übergegangen ist. Seitdem,
steigen nicht nur die Zahlen, sondern sie steigen auf eine Art und Weise, wie sie es bisher nicht gemacht haben und das trägt natürlich ein
ganz klaren Untertitel, der heißt B eins eins sieben
haben's einfach jetzt mit der neuen Virusvariante zu tun, das ist in Großbritannien schon gesehen worden. Kinder sind einfach viel mehr betroffen. Der Bonus, den jüngere gehabt haben im letzten Jahr.
Den gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Das Virus hat in dieser Variante seine Übertragungsfähigkeit so weit verbessert
dass die Hürden, die quasi die kleinsten, äh, dem Virus aufgestellt haben, jetzt locker übersprungen werden und
Jetzt spielt sich eigentlich genau das ab, was man von anderen Infektionskrankheiten schon immer kannte. Kinder, die sind eng beieinander, Kinder, ne.
Lutschen, das gleiche Spielzeug ab.
Ja, also ich meine jeder der ein Kind in der Kita hat, äh vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch früher damals irgendwie, ja, da die bringen jeden Tag irgendeine neue Krankheit nach Hause mit. Das ist da einfach vollkommen normal und man hat sich halt so ein bisschen gewundert, warum das bei Corona nicht ganz so der Fall ist
Und die Erklärung war halt, na ja, das frische Immunsystem ist an der Stelle eine Hürde und ähm,
hat ganz gut funktioniert, während sich eben saß Koff zwei vor allem auf die mittelalten und sehr alten konzentriert hat, da konnte sich eben problemlos ausbreiten. Und das ist jetzt vorbei und
ganze Verteilung teilt sich halt auch noch vor allem deshalb,
um, weil wir eben jetzt die Älteren auch geimpft haben. Das ist halt etwas, was man in diesen Zahlen glaube ich auch ansehen kann. Äh und deswegen kippt quasi das Infektionsgeschehen einfach auf den Kop.
Jetzt sind die Jüngeren, die Treiber und die Älteren fallen langsam raus. Kann man das so zusammenfassen?
Hier, also man kann, sagt quasi, wenn man sich jetzt die zweite Welle.
Und die dritte äh beginnende dritte Welle nebeneinander stellt, dann äh sieht man ganz klar äh einen fast komplett umgedrehtes Bild in der Altersverteilung. Wobei die,
Berufstätigen, Altersgruppen, die sind,
immer stark vertreten und vor allem hat mir auch schon mal rausgearbeitet, berufstätige Frauen. So also die Berufstätigen sind
eigentlich so der das solide Fundament
äh auf das Virus bauen kann, die irgendwie zu jeder Zeit, äh wo es äh zu jeder Zeit bisher in der Pandemie äh dann über Träger gefunden hat.
Ja gut ähm das heißt, so geht's auch weiter.
Ja wie gesagt.
Sagen.
Ja wie gesagt ähm hm.
Prognose vom glaub vom vorletzten Mal Corona dauert dieses Mal etwas länger dieses Jahr etwas länger ja die.
Beginnt sich eben zu.
Die nächsten Wochen ein, zwei Wochen werden jetzt nochmal entscheidend sein dafür.
Ob die Weichenstellungen gelingen oder nicht hm was vielleicht aber auch uns zu,
Gute kommt noch, also so eine Message ist Masken funktionieren. So,
Also Masken sind jetzt im Moment äh glaube ich, wo viele dann auch ähm.
Ja wo wo viele Kontakte herrschen und sagen noch der einzige Damm, wenn jetzt,
wir das so in Fernsehbildern aus Parks jetzt gesehen haben oder ja.
Teilweise auch beim Blick aus dem Fenster sich halt in den Straßen ganz viele unmaskierte Leute nah beieinander tummeln kann wird das nicht gut ausgehen. So da,
hilft uns dann auch kein kein Sommer und kein Sonnenschein.
Und äh ja und es wird wird spannend sein auf jeden Fall die nächsten zwei Wochen die Zahlen weiter im Auge zu behalten, dummerweise haben wir
jetzt wahrscheinlich ähnliches Zahlen, Chaos wieder wie.
Weihnachten rum durch die Feiertage, durch die Schließungen,
werden die Zahlen erstmal so ein bisschen ins Schwanken kommen und werden wahrscheinlich ein, zwei Wochen nach Ostern wieder abwarten müssen, bis sich die Zahlen soweit stabilisiert haben, dass wir auch einen echten Trend,
erkennen können, was sich jetzt durch Ostern halt ergeben kann
ist, dass wir in den Zahlen jetzt Rückgänge und Einbrüche sehen, die aber nicht mit dem realen Infektionsgeschehen äh korrelieren und wo.
Ja dann am Ende wir eine böse Überraschung erleben und,
Das ist natürlich gerade in der Phase, wenn's verhandelt wird, wie geht's weiter, wenn wir nächste Woche oh Zahlen
Zahlen gehen runter. Na, dann können wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen warten
so vielleicht geht's ja doch von alleine zurück, dass
dürfte sich als fatale Fehleinschätzung erweisen äh und insofern wieder ja sehr unglücklich, dass die Entscheidungen gerade wieder in so einen Zeitraum fallen, äh wo mh
wir ja Zahlenschwankungen erwarten äh dürften und uns auf die Zahlen nicht verlassen können.
Aber ähm ja ich meine wir sind jetzt bei den Varianten sind wir jetzt, was B eins eins sieben.
Ankommt, nicht mehr von den quasi hundert Prozent weit entfernt,
so um die neunzig dürften wir liegen, das heißt da kommt jetzt nicht mehr ganz so viel dazu an an R durch die Verbreitung der Varianten,
Das heißt, es gibt ein bisschen Hoffnung, äh dass,
dann wenn die Leute sich disziplinieren oder nicht nicht noch unvorsichtiger werden, dass dann äh zumindest die,
R senkenden Kräfte wieder etwas stärker werden, aber wie wir Deutschland so kennen, dauert hier alles länger. So.
Ähm und es dauert länger, bis die Zahlen hochgehen und es dauert länger, bis die Zahlen runtergehen. Das ist,
halt die, die Crox bei uns, die die das Ganze auch aus.
Laug zu. Anderen Ländern, die lassen das halt schön in die Höhe schießen, bis tausend, dann ist alles Panik, dann geht die Zahl runter. Dann sind, dann atmen alle kurz durch und äh ja, meine nicht, das ist ein Beispiel.
Für uns sein sollte und ja, ich denke wir werden heute auch nicht viel Ausland
machen nur so viel ja von Portugal wurde viel geredet die halt mit 'nem harten Lokdown ganz gute Erfolge erzielt haben und,
ansonsten Polen dreht gerade ein bisschen am Rad, wenn ich das richtig auch in Erinnerung habe, ja.
Euer sehr.
Und ja, Tschechien, gut, dass das schaue ich lieber irgendwie gar nicht hin, die müssten grad wieder auf den Weg nach unten sein. Die machen,
so wirklich, also weiß nicht der der machen den Corona Fahrstuhl in in Perfektion. So, also schneller und öfter rauf und runter ähm,
als dort gehen die Zahlen glaube ich nirgendwo in der Welt.
Nee, also die sind Tschechien ist jetzt am am Ende der dritten den genau genommen sogar schon der vierten Welle, ne?
Also wir sind ja also na ja okay, also dafür.
Die erste war nicht.
Nicht so richtig, ne? Aber so unsere zweite äh Welle, da haben die dann schon mal so nochmal eine dritte und jetzt nochmal eine also wenn man bei der beim bei dem Vergleich bleibt, also die Welle, die die hatten, als wir zweite Welle hatten.
Das waren dann sozusagen gleich zwei Wellen und dann ging's nochmal hoch, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall
nicht schön, Polen steigt gerade massiv, Ungarn ist massiv gestiegen und fällt wieder leicht, also es ist ein Drama, in Europa geht irgendwie nichts zusammen und offensichtlich scheint es auch so eine europäische Krankheit äh zu sein. Wir hatten ja irgendwie in unserem Clubhaus-Talk am am Dienstag ja auch nochmal so einen Einwand äh von jemandem, der,
ne, die die USA äh lebt und sich auch so ein bisschen gefragt hat, wie es denn sein kann, dass dass wir da so unterperformen, dass wir wieder mal einen schönen schönes Ding ins Spiel reingeworfen, das damals, als ja die Europäer.
Amerika besiedelt haben.
Dass das ja so 'ne so 'ne genetische Auslese war, dass die ganzen mutigen die sind irgendwie abgehauen das heißt wir, die wir jetzt hier zurückgeblieben sind, wir sind so 'n bisschen die Weicheier und ähm.
Kriegen jetzt nichts mehr auf die Kette.
Die Vorsichtigen. Also die vorsichtigen und behutsamen und ja.
Und wir haben einfach eben auch eine ältere und vorsichtigere Gesellschaft hier oder ängstlichere könnte man,
auch sagen, das ist nun mal ein Fakt plus eben ja, dass äh wir hier mehr in.
Bestimmten Traditionen verhaftet sind und eben beim Datenschutz und bei,
weil Sicherheitsvorschriften und bei Arbeitsschutz und ganz ganz vielen Dingen, weil nicht immer führend sind, aber doch generell dazu tendieren und auch auch jetzt was das soziale Netz
angeht, da einfach mehr Aufgaben dem Staat zu übertragen und mehr mehr auch an den Staat zu glauben und äh ja, mehr Vorsicht walten zu lassen und
Ja, dafür ich mein das hat, das hat halt auch alles seine zwei Seiten und in den
in den USA zum Beispiel führte diese Forscher dann im Zusammenhang zum zum Impfen
eben auch zu dem weltweit größten und schlimmsten Impfskandal in den fünfziger Jahren, den es gegeben hat, wo eben zweihundertfünfzigtausend.
Gesunde Kinder an Poleo ähm also Kinderlähmung äh erkrankt sind durch
die Impfung, weil der Impfstoff halt
äh zu schnell und zu schlampig äh geprüft worden war oder ein bestimmter Batch, der Impfstoff an sich war okay, sondern
nur die Herstellung ist halt nicht nicht ausreichend überwacht worden und das ist ja, ich mein
heute ist vielleicht in Vergessenheit geraten, welche schlimmen äh Langzeitfolgen äh so Kinderlähmung hat und dann so mal eben zweihundertfünfzigtausend,
Kinder damit zu infizieren mit dieser Krankheit äh ja da muss man sagen ja gut.
Vielleicht hätte man an der Stelle dann doch ein bisschen länger warten sollen. So hinterher ist man natürlich immer klüger, so kann man sagen. Ah ja, Baum haben wir nicht irgendwie das das Ganze schneller gemacht und schneller angefangen zu impfen.
Ja, aber äh was natürlich,
nicht entschuldigt, sind ist halt die Knausrichtigkeit äh bei der Beschaffung. So, das ist halt auch nochmal jetzt klar geworden, die USA haben.
Ganz andere Mengen an Geld auf das Problem geworfen. So, wahrscheinlich so zehn bis zwanzig Mal so viel Geld pro Kopf wie die EU,
und äh ja,
das zahlt sich halt jetzt aus, ich meine wahrscheinlich sind wir mal wieder dann am Ende gnadenlos günstig
oder zumindest unser Gesundheitssystem ist, was Impfkosten angeht, dann oder gnadenlos günstig weggekommen, natürlich nicht was Behandlungen angeht, dass das äh ja
wird sich dann am Ende auch nicht gerechnet haben, denke ich aber, wir haben den Impfstoff am günstigsten gekriegt von allen in der Welt oder worauf können wir stolz sein.
Su
So wenig wie wir Zeit keiner pro Dose ist im Moment.
Immerhin, immerhin, haben wir ein bisschen was gespart. Ja, wir waren jetzt noch ein Jahr länger im im Lokdown, aber wir haben's dreißig Cent billiger bekommen, alles.
Ja, gut, das sind also vermutlich ein paar Milliarden schon, aber natürlich ja.
Geben wir dir an anderer Stelle wieder extra aus.
Offensichtlich ja äh sagen hätte man da einfach,
noch wesentlich Forscher und mutiger äh rangehen müssen und zur Not. Keine Ahnung.
Die halbe Industrie aufkaufen
müssen weltweit die irgendwie was in der Richtung äh produzieren oder neue Kapazitäten hier aufzubauen und äh das genau das haben die Amerikaner auch gemacht. Das ist jetzt nicht nur, dass sie nichts rausrücken,
sondern sie haben auf der anderen Seite aber auch investiert. Das kann man darf man auch nicht vergessen.
Ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass das Deutschland nicht getan hätte, ne? Also ich sage nur das Bion Techwerk in äh Marburg hat ja jetzt gerade seine Pforten geöffnet und es ist ja dann auch schon äh im letzten Jahr irgendwann beschlossen und unterstützt worden.
Ja, nur dafür, dass man sagendem aussichtsreichen äh äh deutschen,
aufstrebenden Impfstoffhersteller hilft seine Produktionskapazitäten auszuweiten darf, das ist jetzt kein
unbedingt mutiger oder besonders äh äh zu lobender Schritt, sondern das ist glaube ich das Minimum, wovon ich rede, ist halt
dass man halt sagen einfach.
Ja äh ein bisschen darüber hinaus äh äh oder hätte gehen können oder sollen oder müssen äh ja rückblickend.
Gut, ja. Auf der anderen Seite äh so ähm.
Hat im letzten Jahr Bestandteil wesentlich mehr Unsicherheit darüber, wann Impfstoffe verfügbar sein würden, also die sagen wir, die.
Die Erwartung vom letzten Sommer wurden zwar übertroffen, denke ich, aber äh ja, das ist glaube ich jetzt nicht mehr so der Maßstab gerade.
Nur vielleicht auch noch, weil USA ähm ja die haben.
Jetzt kein Mangel an Impfstoff und haben jetzt so vielleicht so die Hälfte der Bevölkerung erst geimpft, glaube ich.
Größenordnungsmäßig, aber äh auch dort ist es nicht vorbei und dort herrscht aber jetzt gerade vielfach.
Äh doch so der Glaube sei vorbei und da haben's die Warner gerade ganz ganz schwierig. Ich wollte sagen, was wollt ihr denn? Wir sind doch alle schon so gut wie durchgeimpft.
Aber wir wissen halt, dass selbst in äh.
Population, wo noch dreißig Prozent für das Virus empfängliche vorhanden sind, dass Virusinfektion genug ist
um sich weiter zu vermehren und auszubreiten und,
Gesundheitssystem trotzdem zu überlasten, auch wenn siebzig Prozent geimpft sind und.
Wird es jetzt spannend sein in die USA zu schauen wo vor allem die B eins eins sieben Variante noch eher selten ist. Also die sind da so ein bisschen, wo wir vielleicht im Januar waren oder.
Anfang Februar bei der Variantenverbreitung, weil äh speziell in Kalifornien haben sie ja so ihre eigene Mutante.
Oder eigene Variante die so von der Infektisität zwischen,
Corona Classic und B eins eins sieben liegt so auf auf halben Weg, das heißt, äh, die hat sich dort jetzt ganz gut durchgesetzt, dürfte aber
irgendwann wiederum von B eins eins sieben äh überholt werden, vermute. Ich sehr stark.
Dann erstmal zum Zuge kommt und.
Natürlich die ganzen äh Fluchtmutationen. Skape-Motationen, die wir äh zu erwarten haben. Das haben wir alle äh noch nicht so richtig auf dem Schirm,
und da,
ist dann die kritische Frage, haben wir dafür eigentlich genug Impfstoff bestellt jetzt.
Theoretisch ja, aber kommt es auch alles und äh fällt vielleicht noch der ein oder andere Impfstoff weg und so, also das war so ein, so ein zweites Ding jetzt, meiner Meinung nach, müsste man,
jetzt nochmal schauen.
Man nicht sogar jetzt noch ein bisschen drauflegen kann und eine Sicherheit schafft für den Fall, dass das Problem mit den Fluchtmutationen.
Groß wird oder größer wird als wir das.
Uns jetzt im Moment erhoffen und da ist mir gerade noch nicht genug Panik oder noch nicht genug Sicherheitsbewusstsein da.
Weil wir haben, glaube ich, so äh jetzt für also theoretisch für drei bis vier Impfdosen.
Pro Kopf für dieses Jahr bestellt. Ähm,
aber das wird man natürlich umwandeln müssen dann möglicherweise in bestimmte Verträge und wie gesagt mir ist das so gefühlt noch nicht genug
Sicherheit für den Fall, dass nicht alles so perfekt läuft mit dem Impfstoffen. Äh das,
die zugesagten die vermengen halt dann doch nicht eingehalten werden.
Ich hoffe natürlich, beim Bayern Tech, wenn die jetzt loslegen, äh dass die möglicherweise uns fast eigenhändig äh rausreißen könnten, aber.
Äh ich vermisse so ein bisschen äh Ergebnisse oder Konkretes dieser EU-Task Force, die sich ja darum kümmern soll.
Auch die Mutanten äh im Blick behalten, beziehungsweise die Impfstoffbeschaffung im Hinblick auf,
Mutationen auch vorausschauend planen soll und da ist mir nichts bekannt. Bisher von neuen Bestellungen hast du was gehört.
Ich hab da kein Überblick wie wie es da gerade aussieht an der Bestellfront. Das ist schwierig. Also,
Es wird viel darüber geredet, was jetzt im nächsten Quartal und vielleicht auch noch im dritten Quartal geliefert werden soll und dass das ja so viel sei. Aber ich meine, wenn schon äh der Vizekanzler.
So Zahlen raushaut wie ja da kommen zehn Millionen Dosierungen pro Woche und wir haben irgendwie nichts nirgends wo auch nur ansatzweise was diese Aussage abdecken könnte
dann frage ich mich wirklich, wie das eigentlich so mit der Informationspolitik auf Regierungsebene so aussieht
Ähm unklar. Das können wir vielleicht mal aufgreifen für die nächste Woche. Mal schauen, ob's ob da irgendwas zu finden ist. Derzeit weiß ich's nicht.
Ja? Also mein Punkt war halt nur, dass wir gerade.
Vielleicht alle ein bisschen äh äh oder auch die vor allem die Politik fokussiert ist auf die nächsten Wochen und,
Monate und äh ja mich halt so ein bisschen das Endspiel interessiert. Und äh im Moment äh scheint mir da noch nicht hinreichend Fokus auf dem Endspiel zu liegen.
Mit Sicherheit nicht. Lass uns jetzt mal noch ein paar andere Sachen ab
äh klappern, vor allem wollte ich nochmal ein bisschen Feedback äh aufgreifen, was uns erreicht hat auf äh vielen Wegen, vor allem über die Kommentare
die ihr immer fleißig nutzt, das ist auch gut so, macht es auch weiterhin. Wer sich diese Seite noch gar nicht angeschaut hat, UKW, FM zu jeder Sendung gibt's auch immer ausführliche Links mit allem, was wir hier
behaupten. Das haben wir dann in der Regel auch in irgendeiner Form, sollten wir zumindest mit einem Link äh abgedeckt haben
Ähm eine Sache, die wir letzte Woche aufgegriffen hatten, war das Berliner Impfwunder.
Ja, also auf einmal und zwar am fünfundzwanzigsten dritten.
Soll ähm da irgendwie besonders viel verimpft worden sein in Berlin. Tja.
Ich habe jetzt noch nichts gefunden, was in irgendeiner Form belegt, wurde es auf einmal so hergekommen sein soll.
Du hast wahrscheinlich auch nichts weiter gehört zu dem Thema, ne?
Nee, die Gesundheitssenatorin hat sich dazu zwar irgendwie geäußert und wurde zitiert äh und murmelte irgendwas von Ärzten.
Es gab Auslieferungen, aber diese Meldung, äh die ihr auch in den Kommentaren verlinkt wurden, die waren ja vom fünfundzwanzigsten dritten. Ja, wir blicken aber sozusagen auf äh,
blickend auf diesen fünfundzwanzigsten dritten, an dem so viel stattgefunden haben soll. Also ich will jetzt niemanden unterstellen, dass hier Auslieferungen mit Impfungen gleichgesetzt wurden. Es kann schon sein,
dass das äh im Rahmen dieser Initiative äh gelaufen ist
dass da hundert Ärzte in Berlin äh quasi mit Astra Silika beliefert wurde und ich weiß
dass das stattgefunden hat und da sind auch Leute geimpft worden und ähm ich weiß zumindest von einem Arzt, dass da so in der Größenordnung von hundertsechzig ähm Dosierungen,
ankam.
War das wirklich Astra Sinneka? Ich hörte das sei Bayerntech gewes.
Nein, das war Astra Senika. Das war ja noch kurz bevor die nächste Rolle rückwärts äh stattgefunden hat.
Vorbei. Also das ist auch so.
Skurril gelaufen offenbar. Höre ich meine Argument war ja immer so ein bisschen na ja wenn die Hausärzte es mal haben, dann haben die ja sozusagen ihr ihr kennt die so ihre Leute ja.
Ich hab dann so hinten rum auch über Bekannte gehört die auf einmal so ganz kurzfristig 'n Impftermin bekommen haben.
Weil da noch was übrig war, so nach ein, zwei Tagen dachte ich mir so, hä,
Wenn ihr jetzt wirklich irgendwie strategisch erstmal die Alten plant, so, warum bleibt da jetzt so schnell äh äh was übrig? Kann er jetzt nicht genau sagen, was da passiert ist. Es gab auch andere, die gar nicht erst angefangen haben mit dem Impfen.
Teilweise immer noch nicht, obwohl sie jetzt quasi schon das Zeug im Kühlschrank haben, weil die Kassenärztliche Vereinigung, die das ja alles äh organisiert,
den äh den Ärzten die Ärzte nochmal drauf hingewiesen hat, dass sie ja äh unbedingt diese Impfpriorität einhalten sollen,
das ist ja total wichtig wäre. Und das war halt nicht nur so eine ähm wie soll ich sagen,
Das war nicht nur so eine Empfehlung oder macht das mal so oder so steht das ja irgendwie irgendwo geschrieben und dann sollte das jetzt so ein bisschen hier der äh der Weg sein, den wir gehen. Nein
Sie schreiben da explizit auf ihre Webseite, dass die Missachtung dieser Priorität zu berufsrechtlichen und strafrechtlichen Konsequenzen führen kann.
Ja? Was dann wiederum zur Folge hatte
Dass die Ärzte im Kreis gedreht sind und sich erstmal irgendwie juristisch mit dieser ganzen Frage auseinandergesetzt haben, weil auch gar nicht so genau definiert ist, was denn jetzt sozusagen richtig ist und was falsch ist,
permanent geändert wird, dann wurden die Lehrer mit reingenommen, jetzt sind sie wieder raus, ja? Äh bestimmte Berufe, ja,
nein, Adipös, ja, nein, was genau ist der Grenzwert? Also
da sozusagen so eine so eine so eine Vielzahl von Kriterien, die berücksichtigt werden muss und dann haben sie so dieses Damoklesschwert jetzt auf einmal über sich hängen, so nach dem Motto, na ja, aber wenn du jetzt den falschen impfst, so
wird hier irgendwie deine Proportionen entzogen oder was weiß ich, meine was.
Oder du gehst in den Knast.
Du gehst in den Knast.
Ja das ist natürlich ja eine echte vertrauensbildende Maßnahme so muss man äh muss man sagen ähm ich mein klar.
Ärzte sind auch nur Menschen und äh darunter es gibt auch fehlbare und auch kriminelle und korrupte Ärzte, so wie es halt.
Diese Eigenschaften in vermutlich ziemlich jedem Berufsstand gibt, aber.
Auf der anderen Seite entweder vertraut man jetzt den Ärzten, dass sie äh das machen oder man vertraut ihnen nicht. Ich meine, ich hatte ja,
ganz am Anfang so, warum geht das jetzt über Impfzentren, hatten wir ja diskutiert und dann war natürlich die eine Sache mit, na ja, von wegen,
Logistik äh und so, da bleibt dann wenigstens kein Impfstoff äh über und äh ja.
Aber ich hatte dann auch so ein bisschen in den Raum geworfen, äh dass,
ja die, die das von den Ärzten offenbar auch nicht vertraut, dass äh äh dass sie die Impfreihenfolge einhalten und,
Das äh ja und da scheint das ja eine klare Sprache zu sprechen so dieser dieser,
Äh gut, auf der anderen Seite, was sollen sie natürlich auch auch sagen, sollen sie sagen, ihr dürft jetzt impfen, wen ihr wollt äh damit, aber.
Ja, äh faktisch ist es so.
Aber ich meine, ist ja
das das klingt ja fast so, als ob diese Ärzte noch nie eine Impfung durchgeführt hätten. Und ja und nicht nicht wissen, wie sie irgendwie mit dieser Situation umgehen oder dass sie jetzt irgendwie sofort anfangen, irgendwie alles falsch zu machen.
Ich meine, das war ein Testlauf. Ja, so war das deklariert.
Noch nicht mal von dem Normalbetrieb. Äh ich habe hier auch übrigens auch nochmal die Zahlen, also fünfundzwanzigtausend Impfdosen wurden äh bereitgestellt, ne? Also auch das
deckt sich nicht so richtig mit diesen vierzigtausend an einem Tag. Äh hundert, hundert Praxen sollen daran teilgenommen haben und zweihundertfünfzig Dosen pro Pro Praxis wurden da ausgeliefert,
Also.
Wie immer unklar, äh wir haben einfach viel zu viele unterschiedliche Maßnahmen, jedes Land macht es anders, jedes Land lädt anders ein, jedes Land vergibt diese Prioritäten anders, jedes Land hat unterschiedliche Anweisungen, wer jetzt, wann, wie, wo, bei wem durch wem und wann zu
impfen äh ist. Man kann einfach überhaupt gar keine generellen Aussagen machen und das macht's natürlich auch schwierig zu bewerten
ob das denn jetzt bei diesem Geschehen alles richtig läuft oder nicht, aber Vertrauen schafft das auf jeden Fall nicht besonders.
Bis hin zu, dass halt.
Wie viel nach Altersindikation und wie viel Nachhör man beruflicher Indikation verimpft wurde sich auch extrem unterscheidet,
zwischen den Ländern, sodass man halt auch bei der Frage wie viel Prozent der über achtzigjährigen sind denn jetzt in welchem Land geimpft? Das lief beim letzten Mal auch so zwischen zwanzig Prozent und,
siebzig Prozent oder dreißig und siebzig Prozent lagen äh die Werte auseinander.
Und wir wussten's nur bei neun von sechzehn Bundesländern.
Ja genau. Manche äh waren dann sogar noch extra Datensparsam.
Ja, Datensparsame. Also überhaupt die ganze Impfkampagne. Ich meine, ich gucke jetzt gerade mal wieder auf das Impfdasport.
Und ich habe mich irgendwie heute über zwei Sachen gewundert. Ich habe mich gewundert, warum immer noch nicht die Zahl für Donnerstag da ist. Und ich habe mich gewundert, warum ich keine Buchung auf meinem Bankkonto habe, bis mir dann einfiel, verdammte Axt, heute ist ja wieder so ein Feiertag.
Heute ist ja Karfreitag und ähm das ist natürlich klar, Karfreitag kann man natürlich auf einer Webseite keine Zahlen irgendwie anzeigen.
Weil wenn Tanzen schon verboten ist, dann kann man nicht irgendwie auch noch einen Impf-Dashboard äh aktualisieren, weil da müsste ja irgendjemand äh am Freitag die Zahlen vom Donnerstag eingeben.
Geht natürlich nicht.
Israelis das machen mit ihrem strengen Sonntagsverbot.
Die impfen wahrscheinlich sogar am Schabbat.
Ja, dann darf man sich normalerweise nichts erlauben, aber geimpft wird sogar am Schabbat.
Na ja. Okay, um diese Impfsituation vielleicht noch äh abzurunden, wir haben jetzt äh wiederum.
Die Rolle rückwärts, hat man schon kurz erwähnt, Astra Sinika ist jetzt generell für Leute unter sechzig äh erstmal nicht empfohlen und wird von daher entsprechend nicht verimpft. Termine werden umgelegt
Gut, es gab weitere Fälle von dieser Sinus ähm Thrombosengeschichte.
Und es scheint darüber immer noch keine absolute Klarheit zu geben, also hat man beschlossen, dass jetzt erstmal wieder einzustellen und stattdessen Astra Senika für die Älteren zu benutzen, ja.
Die, die es am Anfang,
gar nicht kriegen sollten. Okay, man kann das so in der Reihe, kann man das alles nachvollziehen, warum's so gelaufen ist, aber dass das insgesamt nicht gut läuft,
weil er auch noch die Firma Astra Senika auch noch äh mit der EU im Krieg steht und so weiter, das ist glaube ich jetzt auch klar geworden. Ich frage mich halt bloß immer noch, warum eigentlich.
Astra Sinneka jetzt hier irgendwie äh in Probleme gerät und die anderen äh Impfstoffe äh nicht. Ja,
Gibt da verschiedene Vermutungen, dass vielleicht die Dosis zu groß war oder so, das werden wir glaube ich alles demnächst noch mitbekommen. Aber um nochmals auf die Organisation zurückzukommen.
Dass die nächste Sache ist ja, jetzt hatten wir, wie die Schulen geöffnet, unter anderem mit diesem Versprechen ja jetzt impfen wir hier die ganzen Lehrer.
Die dann aber alle Astra Senika bekommen sollten,
Und jetzt halt nur noch die Lehrer, die quasi sechzig und älter sind, sind immer noch viel zu viele, aber die können jetzt sozusagen mit Assa Sinika geimpft werden, ob die das dann wollen, das steht nochmal auf einer ganz äh einer ganz anderen Tabelle.
Aber die anderen haben's nicht. Außerdem wurde dann wiederum diese Impfpriorisierung zurückgenommen, das heißt, sie sind jetzt nicht mehr in der Gruppe zwei, sondern in der Gruppe drei, weil ja sonst nicht genug Impfstoff für alle da wäre,
Was dann wiederum dazu führt, dass alte äh Lehrer, die jetzt in Osterfeen einen Impftermin hatten, denen dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht wahrnehmen können.
Stellt sich dann wiederum die Frage, okay, was ist dann, wenn die Schulen nach den Osterferien wieder aufmachen sollen.
Dann habt ihr quasi diese Prämisse nicht erfüllt, so nach dem Motto, ja, was wollt ihr denn? Die Lehrer sind doch geimpft. Weil sind sie dann nicht.
Äh es dreht sich alles im Kreis. Also ich denke mal sowieso, dass.
Was für ein Snap.
Ja, was heißt da wo? Ich meine, ich gehe eh nicht davon aus, A, dass, dass die Schulen wieder aufmachen.
Ja. Mhm.
Weil glaube ich äh das dann einfach.
Soweit ist und zweitens glaube ich auch, dass äh immer mehr Eltern dann auch einfach ihre Kinder nicht mehr in die Schule schicken werden und damit sind sie wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut beraten. Also meine blanden auf jeden Fall zu Hause.
Also es ist wie gesagt noch nie auch in der Pandemie war so klar äh wo.
Jetzt ja die Infektion sich am meisten ausbreitet und die dritte Welle ist.
Ganz klar jetzt eine, die von der Öffnung der Schulen und Kindergärten ausging.
Man ist es ja so.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, die Schulen und Kindergärten sind jetzt Schuld daran. Ja, das das passiert, sondern ähm.
Es gibt eben ganz, ganz viele Bereiche, in denen mehr oder weniger Infektion stattfindet.
So und äh wir müssen, wir wir können eigentlich keinen Bereich zulassen. Wir müssen halt in allen Bereichen äh reduzieren und.
Jetzt äh sind es halt äh nun mal aktuell, aber gerade.
Schulen und die Kindergärten, die uns über die einzeben, die den Unterschied machen zwischen sinkenden und fallenden Zahlen. Genauso,
ist es aber ähm auch der Großteil der berufstätigen Bevölkerung ähm an ihrem Arbeitsplatz und auf ihrem Arbeitsweg die,
ebenfalls für Verbreitung sorgen, so das heißt wenn man die reduzieren würde wären wir auch unter eins und.
So kann man halt alle möglichen Dinge äh rausgreifen und nur das halt die einen wie zum Beispiel Veranstaltungen oder.
Äh Gastronomie äh irgendwo in der in der Mitte eben mehr zur Senkung beigetragen haben und mehr darunter.
Leiden äh mussten und dauerhaft zu sind und dann gibt's halt eben so ein paar und dazu gehören die die Schulen und die Kitas und
die die Unternehmen hm die,
halt, will nicht sagen, Narrenfreiheit äh hatten äh letztere, aber deren
ja Beitrag zur Senkung der Ausbreitung, sehr bescheiden ausgefallen. Es werden halt andere Teile der Gesellschaft und unser aller Privatleben äh doch am meisten gefordert waren und
ich muss auch äh sagen eigentlich ähm.
Ja gut, vielleicht gibt es viele Leute, die sich diesen Luxus äh nicht erlauben können, aber äh so ist es ja jetzt viel die Rede von äh Live Work Balance und.
Finde oder traditionell ist es so, mit Arbeit kannst du alles entschuldigen im Privat. Ich muss arbeiten oder ja ich kann jetzt nicht, ich äh ja, wie auch immer. Also da ist äh.
Da ist normalerweise in neun von zehn Fällen, wenn.
Irgendwie einen beruflichen Termin oder eine berufliche Anforderung gibt dann.
Gewinnt die bei den meisten Leuten, weil es geht ja auch um Broterwerb und was es wichtiger als als Broterwerb, aber am.
Du willst ja nicht nur leben, um zu arbeiten, so du brauchst äh äh man muss ja für irgendwas arbeiten und deswegen äh finde ich es,
ganz gut, äh also ich hab für mich vor Jahrzehnten schon diese Selbstverständlichkeit,
geschafft, als ich also speziell ja als ich dann Familienvater geworden bin, war klar, ich kann das, also wenn ich
jedes Mal automatisch beruflichen Anforderungen den Vorrang gebe vor privaten, dann führt das äh in die Katastrophe und zu Unzufriedenheit und deswegen
dann irgendwann explizit beschlossen, es gibt keine Priorität von vornherein, sondern.
Sagen, ich werde in jedem Einzelfall abwägen äh so wie wichtig ist jetzt das.
Berufliche und wie wichtig ist das Private und wenn halt da erstmal ein privater Termin steht, dann ist der auch geblockt für berufliche Termine und und weicht nicht automatisch äh so.
Und äh ja,
Und in der Pandimie aber habe ich das Gefühl, dass das private so äh leider bei den meisten Leuten äh
untergebuttert wird, dass am Ende dann doch gesagt wird, naja, ist ja Arbeit, wir müssen ja was zu essen äh haben und deswegen ja äh.
Dürfen wir da nicht so so äh stark ran, ja?
Ja gut, ist ja auch nachvollziehbar. Also.
Ja, nur.
Das kann's ja nicht sein, oder? Äh ich meine, dass das sagen äh äh und daher stammt natürlich wahrscheinlich auch auch viel von diesem von diesem Gefühl, der der,
Unzufriedenheit,
dass eben ja die Dinge, die Spaß machen, mehr eingeschränkt werden als die Dinge, die eher lästig äh sind oder nicht so viel Spaß machen. Wobei jetzt nicht.
Sagen will, dass das Arbeit nicht Spaß macht, äh so auch vielen Leuten. Das kam bei Umfragen auch raus, dass die meisten Deutschen gerne arbeiten.
Gehen angeblich.
Zufrieden sind mit ihrem Job, ja äh so hm also irgendwie sechzig Prozent oder so, haben gesagt, super, mein Job ist geil. Äh,
alles gut. Ähm ja, nur.
Ja wie ich fand gestern habe ich ja überlegt, wann hab ich das letzte Mal ein Fassbier getrunken.
Sowie lange äh ja, ist es her. So und das ist dann dann auch so ein Ding.
Angesagt hat, mag ja auch zynisch sein, aber die am Ende lang ist, ist mir da dann ähm sagen mein Fass Bier dann auch wichtiger als deine Oma. Äh jedenfalls emotional.
Ne? Ähm und das ist dann natürlich auch was äh ja viele Jugendliche bewegt, aber faktisch ähm ist es so, dass das äh natürlich im im.
Wir wir eben Menschen sind und äh damit halt ja.
Etwas weiterentwickelte Affen am Ende des Tages und,
ja Vernunft halt eher diese ganze ganze Großhirn so, das mit der Vernunft, dass es halt draußen angebaut an an unser Gehirn, das ist jetzt nicht so die,
die Zentrale Maschinerie, die äh uns Dinge tun oder lassen lässt, sondern die muss halt ja.
Auch äh das das Irre tun, die Vernunft und am Ende ja am Ende hm.
Ist es dann doch eine emotionale Bewertung, die den Ausschlag gibt für jede Entscheidung, so unser, unser Emotion, unser emotionales Subsystem äh.
Es reagiert am Ende alles, weil jede Bewertung, jede Entscheidung führt am Ende zu einer Emotion und,
äh die lässt uns dann äh entscheiden oder nicht entscheiden, egal wie rational die Gründe äh äh sein mögen oder wo wir es, wo wir es her haben, am Ende,
werten wir rationales auch emotional, sonst.
Sonst würden wir äh nichts tun, muss ich sagen. Wenn eben nicht so wäre, könnten wir uns nicht entscheiden.
Möchte aber trotzdem an dieser Stelle nochmal kurz festhalten. Im Zweifelsfall ist die die Oma von jemandem schon auch wichtig. Also vielleicht wichtiger Eis, ein Fassbier.
Dass äh.
Sagen ähm ja, so sollte es sein, so, aber äh mein Punkt war, wenn man, wenn man ehrlich ist,
so ja.
Fällt jetzt nicht deine Oma oder so äh aber äh so die die sagen wir so, die Oma von irgendjemanden, äh die man nicht kennt äh so.
Also ich würde, ich würde, ich würde, ich würde noch diverse Fass Biere opfern für andere Leute, Omas, ähm,
bin ich irgendwie recht entspannt, aber das hat eben auch was mit dieser Grundhaltung zu tun, die ich vorhin schon geäußert habe, die einfach so mein, mein Defold äh ist. Ich nehme die Situation einfach
so wie sie ist und äh meine Erwartungen sind niedrig. So, ich hab.
Schon auch Erwartungen, die liegen aber sehr weit in der Zukunft. Ich habe wenig Erwartungen, die in der nahen Zukunft liegen. Ich würde sagen, die naheste Erwartung, die ich habe.
Ist in drei Monaten, das ist so ein Zeitraum, von dem ich immer ausgehe.
Dass innerhalb dieses Zeitraums Dinge besser werden könnten, wenn denn das Richtige getan wird.
Es ist dann immer sehr enttäuschend nach drei Monaten zu sehen, wenn ich das Richtige getan wurde. Aber da würde ich sagen, liegt so so ein bisschen meine äh Hoffnungshorizont
Wenn man sich dann diesen Zeitpunkt dann auch äh genähert hat und er vielleicht nur noch einen Monat entfernt ist, dann weiß ich ja auch schon, dass es dann irgendwie nichts mehr wird. Von daher habe ich dann wieder meine Zukunft auf die auf den Zeitraum,
drei Monate von dort aus wieder umgebucht.
Damit wir uns jetzt vielleicht nicht äh zu lange mit dieser Diskussion aufhalten, nochmal äh ein Feedback aufgreifen wollend vom letzten Mal, der wir hatten ja sehr viel über Schnelltests geredet.
Und vor allem haben wir,
mal die Gelegenheit genutzt, mal konkret durchzurechnen, wie sich denn das alles so verhält mit äh Empfindlichkeit und Genauigkeit dieser Tests und wie man denn das so auszurechnen hat, wovon man denn so ausgehen kann. Insbesondere im Hinblick auf,
die Idee Schnelltest bei Veranstaltungen zu verwenden als alleinige oder zusätzliche Absicherung.
Ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck gewonnen für den Kommentaren,
uns dann gleich damit unterstellt wurde, dass wir quasi jetzt in Schnelltest überhaupt gar keinen Sinn und Nutzen sehen. Und die sozusagen ablehnen oder als als nicht hilfreich äh ansehen.
Da würde ich mich jetzt falsch äh,
verstanden fühlen so ähm es man muss glaube ich wirklich zwei Sachen unterscheiden, ja? Also Schnelltests können selbstverständlich helfen in definierten Situationen bestimmte Risiken tragbar zu machen.
Bleiben dann aber immer noch Risiken. Im Großen und Ganzen aber eben als.
Mechanismus, der in die Gesellschaft gedruckt wird, quasi als Ausrede dafür, dass man dann andere Dinge unterlässt.
Die letzten Endes dann nur dazu führen, dass man eben das Infektionsgeschehen nicht einhegt, sondern dass das Infektionsgeschehen dann sich dadurch noch weiter äh entfacht durch diese Maßnahmen
wie wir das jetzt bei den Schulen zum Beispiel gesehen haben und weiterhin sehen. Die Zahlen haben wir ja schon diskutiert. Das sehen wir kritisch.
Und das eine kann wahr sein und das andere auch.
Die aus meiner Sicht die Rolle, die Schnelltests spielen können. Ähm.
Ist, dass wenn.
Fallende Zahlen da sind. Wenn also wir einen R von deutlich unter.
Eins haben und wir niedrige Institzen haben und mit niedrig meine ich einstellig so.
Dann äh in so einer Situation können dann Tests halt,
tatsächlich helfen sagen dieses Öffnungspotential was man hat und Öffnungspotential würde ich,
sehen ist der Abstand wie viel R unter eins man hat. Das ist das Öffnungspotential. Oberoberhalb von eins,
gibt es gar kein Öffnungspotential, ja? Nur unter eins. So und wenn man dann in so einer Situation,
von diesem Öffnungspotential dann möglichst wenig ausschöpfen will, sondern weiter unter eins bleiben will, dann kann man halt äh sagen, das als,
zusätzlich hier oder flankierende Maßnahmen einsetzen, so.
Oberhalb von eins Jahr macht das die Situation äh äh.
Verschlimmert das die Situation weniger als wenn man's nicht tun würde, aber.
Verschlimmert die Situation trotzdem, ja? Und da helfen eben die Tests nicht die Situation nicht zu verschlimmern, ja?
So und.
Ja, das kann man glaube ich auch nicht oft genug äh wiederholen. Und äh ja und was halt auch,
so aus dem Nachgang der Debatte noch blieb ist, dass.
Masken deutlich zuverlässiger und mehr schützen als.
Irgendwelche Testregime, die man fahren kann, egal ob Schnelltests oder PCR und täglich und so Maske.
Ist im Zweifelsfall besser,
Maske ist im Zweifelsfall auch äh sagen, schützt deutlich mehr als Impfung, das kann man auch nochmal wiederholen, weshalb diese ganze Sache mit dem mit dem grünen Impfpass äh eigentlich,
Quatsch ist. So. Also ähm oder vielleicht nicht kompletter Quatsch, aber wenn,
sagen von einem Maskenträger weniger Gefahr ausgeht als äh von einem geimpften, dann äh müsste eigentlich ähm sagen, wenn man sich verpflichtet, äh sagen,
Maske zu tragen, äh stellt man ein geringeres Risiko dar, als äh wenn man,
einfach nur geimpft ist und deswegen auch wird in den Ländern selbst wo halt viel geimpft wurde zumindest ist das Maskentragen damit nicht obsoliert geworden, falls sich jemand
Falls jemand darauf hofft dass das mit den Impfungen oder dass die eigene Impfung.
Dazu beiträgst. Masken können wir erst abnehmen, wenn ein Groß, wenn alle geimpft sind oder genug geimpft sind, so.
Ja
Wird wahrscheinlich stattfinden und ich will das auch nochmal ein bisschen einschränken, was du sagst. Du gehst davon aus, dass.
Wenn man die Maske perfekt trägt, dass es dann irgendwie ein besserer Schutzwirkung hat, so, ne? Das äh spricht insofern für die Impfung, weil die dann eben nicht unbedingt mehr so sehr vom Verhalten abhängig ist oder dass man irgendwas richtig bedient.
Ja und natürlich senkt sie auch das Risiko, dass dann äh ein Tourist dann dem einheimischen äh äh Gesundheitssystem zur Last fällt, dass also äh von daher äh.
Sagen.
Es ist das durchaus 'n ein stichhaltiger Grund aber ja davon alleine und sagen hm,
dass alleine rechtfertigt jetzt keine größere,
Freiheit oder Handlungsfreiheit äh sage ich mal im im Alltag, egal ob dann im Innen- oder im Ausland.
Das war halt mein Punkt.
Weiteres äh Feedback gab's dann auch rund um die Diskussion um Veranstaltung und konkret dann auch das Konzept,
Fusion Veranstaltung, die ich hier vorgestellt hatte, die sich ja extrem viel äh Gedanken gemacht haben und da einen sehr aufwendigen Hygieneplan vorgelegt haben, mit dem sie eben Gedenken ihre Veranstaltungen im Sommer,
äh zu beantragen.
Also mit PCR-Test, Schnelltest und so weiter. Ich will das jetzt nicht alles wiederholen, könnte zur Note nochmal nachhören. Wenn ihr die letzte Folge noch nicht gehört habt, ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Dazu gab's einen Kommentar von Van Thomas
schreibt. Beim Thema Fusion bin ich ehrlich gesagt sehr skeptisch, ob das eine gute Idee ist, selbst wenn man annimmt, dass
Konzept zu neunundneunzig Prozent wasserdicht ist und die Kosten dafür noch tragbar sind. Also alles so läuft, wie die Leute sich das in ihrem Kopf ausgedacht haben und nicht die Wirklichkeit dazwischen kommt.
Problematisch sehe ich halt das Signal, was damit ausgesinnt wird. Wenn dann Bilder in der Presse erscheinen, die eine Horde Partypeople zeigen, dann dreht auch der Rest der Menschen in der Republik komplett durch. Absolut niemand wird sich noch an irgendwelche Regeln halten.
Und weiter, Tim sagte ja, wenn er wenn das nicht erlaubt wird, dann rumort es umgekehrt wird das aber auch so passieren, wenn die Polizei mal wieder irgendwo eine private Geburtstagsfeier auflöst,
Ich habe dazu auch direkt äh geantwortet und lese einfach mal kurz meine Antwort vor,
die äh Signale der Politik, die Lockerung fordert, sind andere Signale als die Wünsche der Betroffenen. Wir reden.
Über eine Perspektive für Ende Juni und die Zeit danach. Die Politik sollte heute alles dafür tun, dass es im Sommer so eine Option geben kann.
Möglich wäre das und unter diesen Rahmenbedingungen eine Genehmigung zu erteilen und auch eine Überlebensgarantie zu leisten
diese Bedingungen nicht geschaffen werden und die Veranstaltung wieder abgesagt werden, wäre jetzt nötig
Für eine Branche, die als einzige seit einem Jahr komplett eingestellt wurde, während andere Branchen nicht nur weitermachen konnten, sondern dabei auch fröhlich die Panemie weiter befeuert haben,
Und wir wissen auch,
so oder so irgendeine Ferienaktivität in diesem Land geben wird, egal was die Zahlen sagen, wenn das stattfindet, aber ein Festival, was mit Sicherheit hundert Mal mehr für die Sicherheit tut als jeder Campingplatz
darf nicht sein, dann wird es sehr viel Unmut geben und den verstehe ich auch sehr gut.
Ja, das wollte ich jetzt nochmal nach äh schieben, weil ich das gesagt habe, dann rumort es und so weiter, das äh konnte man natürlich auch.
Falsch verstehen, aber mir ging's im Prinzip genau um diese Perspektive. Diese Veranstaltungen blicken bisschen, also im Gegensatz zur Politik blicken diese Veranstaltungen in die Zukunft,
Die haben einen Plan. Und zwar in extrem detaillierten, ausgefeilten Plan und arbeiten da dran
ja und mit Software und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir sogar sicher, dass wir das mit der Software hinbekommen. Die kriegen ihr PCR-Testing und ihre Notification mit ihrem Ticketsystem kombiniert. Werden die hinkriegen. Kriegen die auf jeden Fall hin, ja? Das ist einfach mal
das wird laufen und die Politik macht halt ihren Teil nicht. Indem sie halt alles waage hält.
Und wir haben das ja eingangs so schon ausführlich diskutiert überhaupt keine Maßnahmen ergreift, um dann überhaupt ein Envirement zu liefern, in dem stattfindet, ja? Und natürlich müssen die jetzt entscheiden. Und natürlich ist es leist,
es wäre möglich, in drei Monaten diese Situation herzustellen, wenn man jetzt reagieren würde.
Was dich geschieht, ja, was irgendwann noch geschehen wird, aber unter Umständen halt so spät, dass dann eben diese Veranstaltung vor der Situation stehen, dass sie zwar tausendfach geplant haben.
Riesige Investitionen gemacht haben, siebzigtausend Leute verrückt gemacht haben,
und dann irgendwie ausfällt und dann die Kosten davon zu tragen haben. Dann müssen sie es auch noch ausbaden, dafür, dass sie irgendwie diesen Mut gezeigt haben. Man kann von denen nicht erwarten.
Dass sie jetzt sagen ach, ihr tut alle nichts. Na dann sind wir halt nochmal ein Jahr arbeitslos.
Was soll's? Machen wir doch gerne. Haben wir doch kein Problem mit. Wir liegen ja eh nur auf der faulen Haut rum.
So läuft das nicht. Zwar dieses Jahr wird wird diese Branche, die jetzt gerade noch Mühe und Not zusammengehalten wird, wird komplett übern äh komplett Hops gehen
Ja und dann gibt's nächstes Jahr gar keine Veranstaltung. Ja, was einfach die passende Branche dazu nicht gibt
Gut, so wird's natürlich auch nicht laufen, aber weißt schon, es ist auf jeden Fall da werden jetzt wirklich ähm die Weichen gestellt. Man muss einfach einen Weg finden,
wie man,
Den einzigen, die irgendwie in der Lage sind, wirklich langfristig zu planen, denen auch eine Perspektive bietet, beziehungsweise ihnen diese Perspektive auch absichert, entweder durch politische Maßnahmen oder,
Im Idealfall eben auch durch die Absicherung des Risikos.
Und das ist eigentlich die einzige Forderung, die hier auf dem Tisch steht und die kann ich äh sehr gut verstehen. Dieses Ding mit dem Signal, ja, also dann dann wird auf einmal wieder den Partys.
Festivals, die sich so viel Gedanken machen, mehr als jedes, jedes Büro in Deutschland. Ähm.
Irgendwie dann unterstellt, die werden jetzt sozusagen Schuld an allem,
Die einzigen, die irgendwie schon komplett den Betrieb eingestellt haben, während irgendwie der Rest den Sommer bei niedrigen Institzen irgendwie glücklich im Biergarten äh verlebt hatten und auf Campingplätzen. Ja, die sind dann auf einmal Schulz oder diese.
Hab auch wirklich ein Problem damit so 'n Feindbild aufzubauen.
Aus Leuten, das knüpft so ein bisschen an den letzten Block, den wir jetzt hier schon äh hatten auch an. Äh die daran arbeiten, dass Leute Spaß haben.
Also die wirklich ihr Leben als solches ausleben so einfach nicht arbeiten und nicht.
Ja und wenn's auch für manche nur ein Wochenende ist in diesem Jahr.
Was dann einfach eine große Rolle spielt und im Falle der Fusion mal ganz nebenbei in dem Moment, wo sie eben auch beweisen würden, dass dieses Modell funktioniert, eine eine Blaupause schaffen für sehr viele andere, denen die halt äh im ähnlichen Feld arbeiten.
Mir ist leider noch eine Unzulänglichkeit aufgefallen an dem Konzept.
Oder könnte sagen eine Sache, die eigentlich man noch verbessern könnte und zwar.
Willst du die Leute alle zwei nochmal zwei oder drei Tage nach der Veranstaltung komplett durchtesten.
So, das ist ja bisher nicht vorgesehen, weil was ist es.
Hat dir auch erzählt. Also es wird am Anfang bei der Anreise ein erster Test genommen. PCR.
Die Leute, die in Busse springen, nach Abgabe dieser Probe werden vor Antritt dieser Busreise nochmal zusätzlich geschnelltestet.
Und dann in Masten in den Bussen zu dieser Veranstaltung. Manche fahren auch mit dem eigenen Wagen an, aber sehr viele fahren auf diese Party mit Bussen.
Wenn sie dann ankommen am Gelände, dann ist das Ergebnis ihres PCR-Tests da. Das kann also für manche Leute bedeuten, dass sie dann wieder zurück müssen. So, dann ist Party, die Fusion geht über drei, vier Tage und zur Halbzeit.
Wird einmal das gesamte Gelände geräumt und die Leute müssen beim Rausgehen nochmal eine Probe abgeben und das wird dann gepoolt auch noch mit den eigenen nochmal PCR getestet.
Mit den Facilities Onside,
Und nur wer bei diesen Pooltests nicht auffällt als positiv, also klar, ne? Die werden also gepoolt heißt, fast halt mehrere zusammen, ist einer äh davon ähm.
Also ist, ist ein Pool positiv, dann werden die Proben nochmal einzeln äh genommen und einzeln PCR getestet, damit man weiß, wer es ist und die Person muss dann halt raus.
Ja, also das ist das Modell.
Ja. Aber wo, genau, wo was ich meinte ist, dass du eigentlich um sicher zu gehen.
Nochmal äh dann, wenn die Leute wieder zu Hause sind, so sagen zwei oder drei Tage.
Nachdem sie weg sind vom Festival äh willst du eigentlich auch nochmal alle durchtesten? Und zwar.
Aus folgendem Grund, das ist mir auch erst dann in der Woche aufgefallen, ich bin auf mehrere Fälle äh gestoßen.
Wo genau im Kontext mit Veranstaltungen eben während der Veranstaltung jeden Tag und auch am letzten Tag noch geprüft wurde und,
man niemanden gefunden hat, aber im Nachgang sich doch rausstellte, dass dann offenbar am vorletzten oder letzten Tag
nochmal zu einem super Spreading gekommen sein muss, bei dem sich äh so ich glaube fünfundzwanzig von neunzig
anwesenden infiziert haben und äh nur die die ganze Zeit eine Maske auf hatten sind, äh äh davon gekommen, so.
Wenn man also äh jetzt wirklich sicher gehen will, dass nicht doch am letzten Tag
irgendwo einen super streading passiert ist, ähm braucht man eigentlich noch einen Test, so wie gesagt, zwei, drei Tage,
nach Ende der Veranstaltung, um dann quasi Resümee ziehen zu können und sagen zu können, seht ihr, ähm, alle,
waren da und ähm sagen falls tatsächlich am letzten Tag noch irgendwas passiert ist, so, weil.
Ob das jetzt drei Tage stattfindet oder einen Tag gerade das sagen kann halt am letzten Tag kann halt,
eben auch noch genug schlimmes äh pass passieren. So und damit,
hättest du sagen auch diese Folgen oder Konsequenzen davon,
gefangen. Das heißt, dass zumindest man dann eventuell doch noch doch vom Festival ausgehende Infektionsketten man dann im Nachgang auch nochmal recht gut abschneiden könnte.
Aber das ist natürlich im Gegensatz zu den anderen geplanten Tests, logistischen und viel größeres Problem
und natürlich auch nicht so leicht, ich sag mal erzwingbar oder dass die Leute dann sagen
war jetzt halt auf dem Festival und äh da müsste man dann halt auch noch ein Incentive äh für schaffen, vermute ich, damit die Leute das machen. Und dann,
wird's natürlich endgültig wahrscheinlich einfach finanziell äh,
ja, ist das wahrscheinlich sowieso schon grenzwertig, die ganz.
Absolut, ja.
Und wenn man da jetzt noch mehr draufpackt, kann das kann das auch leicht sein, dass es dann genau äh so eine Anforderung wäre, die das dann auch wieder über den über den Rand äh puscht, aber,
Ja, vor dem, wie gesagt, vor dem Hintergrund, dass,
eben dir bei jedem, bei jeder einzelnen Testung, äh die du durchführst, es trotzdem möglich ist, dass dir Superstradter durchrutschen ähm und,
da willst du halt noch so viele Sicherheitsdecken einziehen, wie du willst und meiner Meinung nach.
Fehlt da noch eine, um damit ich, also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Amtsleiter wäre, so ähm.
Wäre das für mich dann eher, sagen wir mal die, die letzte Sicherheit, das was auch immer dann passiert, äh so äh nach der Veranstaltung sich die Folgen dann sagen, äh wenn alles schief geht, doch noch einfangen lassen.
Weiß nicht, wie du das siehst.
Na ja, ich sehe extreme logistische Probleme an einem letzten Tag noch so eine Aktion zu machen.
Wenn ich nicht am letzten Tag, sondern drei Tage nach, nach nachdem alle weg sind.
Ja, aber dann sind ja alle weg, wie willst du die dann alle dort testen.
Ja, ne, die müssten sich dann irgendwo, wo auch immer zu Hause irgendwo dann äh zu einem Test äh melden oder ja, ich sage ja, das ist.
Aber dazu kannst du die, ja, nein, das dazu kannst du die Leute nicht zwingen.
So, manche werden es vielleicht tun. Ich denke, dass die Fusion an der Stelle.
Zumindest mit dem, also man äußern sich ja auch nochmal explizit dazu, dass sie sagen, ihr solltet auf jeden Fall, also sie empfehlen, explizit nochmal die Conavan App.
Weil die tatsächlich äh im Kontext von so einem Festival glaube ich auch ganz gut funktionieren kann,
Ja, weil die tatsächlich eben an der Stelle genau das Richtige tut, so Nähe und so weiter und da hast du es auch nicht so viel mit Indoor zu tun, sondern es ist halt einfach alles draußen. Ähm das kann dann eben bei einer späteren Infektion auch noch helfen.
Bei mir wie gesagt war's vielleicht auch beim letzten Mal schon gemerkt bleibt bei allem Verständnis dafür dass natürlich diese Situation,
mit, dass dann am Ende alle auf Campingplätzen sitzen und sagen, ungeschützte Kontakte haben und dann aber Veranstaltungen weiterhin mh.
Unmöglich bleiben, ja? Das ist einerseits schwer erträglich.
So auf der anderen Seite ja aus meiner Sicht bei niedrigen Institenzen machbar auch.
Sogar ja,
weniger hohen Auflagen machbar, denke ich. Aber eben, ja, dazu brauchen wir die niedrigen Institenzen,
Und äh ohne die ich meine, da waren wir uns ja auch einig. Äh eine Zeit das beste Testkonzept nichts.
Ähm ja.
Das kann man jetzt alles fünf Mal hin und herrollen und noch tausend Argumente äh äh bringen, die ja auch hier in dem Testkonzept noch gemacht werden, die vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt jeder so versteht, ja? Äh speziell ist ja auch jetzt, sagen wir mal, dieses ähm diese Szene bei äh
Alternativen Festivals.
Was steht ja hier in der Präame auch schon drin? Auf der einen Seite zeichnet die sich ohnehin schon dadurch aus, dass da eigentlich ein sehr hohes ähm.
Soll ich sagen, die Verantwortung für die anderen da einfach ein hohes Gut ist? Also es ist kein sich so eine Persaka Veranstaltung äh.
Wo sich alle,
prügeln und besoffen durch die Gegend ziehen. Das hat einfach eine ganz andere Dynamik. Und ähm ja, nicht zu Unrecht sind, dass auch die Leute, die jetzt gerade diese Impfzentren dann auch äh durchführen. Also es ist einfach,
finde ich. Haben sie da einen guten Punkt? Aber ich will da jetzt gar nicht weiter drauf eingehen. Ich will mich jetzt hier auch nicht hinstellen und sagen, das ist jetzt äh
Total geiler Scheiß, das müsst ihr jetzt auf jeden Fall unbedingt machen, sondern ich wollte es vorstellen auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite äh damit auch nochmal differenzieren, was jetzt hier eigentlich getan werden muss. Natürlich müssen diese Leute, diese Veranstalter,
müssen sich Gedanken machen, das erwarten wir ja auch davon.
Aber wir können nicht von ihnen erwarten, dass sie jetzt schon auf das Versagen der Politik setzen und selber den Rückzug antreten für etwas, was in vier, fünf oder sechs Monaten stattfinden soll.
Wer macht denn das sonst in dieser Gesellschaft? Das macht niemand, das kann man von keinem erwarten. Ich habe auch Planungen für den Sommer. Ich brauche sogar eine Planung für den Sommer. Unbedingt.
Warum? Weil das auch das Prinzip Hoffnung ist. Wenn ich jetzt sage ähm an die.
Zwei Sommer zwanzig einundzwanzig.
Ich bleibe jetzt einfach noch den nächsten Winter auch noch komplett irgendwie in meiner Bewegungsarmut äh drin und ich treffe niemanden.
Das ist meine Vorbereitung auf das Jahr. Ich bitte dich, das macht niemand.
Alle wollen irgendwas haben, worauf sie sich hinschauen können und für viele ist es halt auch noch Existenz äh bedrohend, ja? Das zerreißt auch
Communitys und dass das halt alles auch
langfristige Konsequenzen, ne? Allein dadurch, dass eben dieses kulturelle Leben äh so eine so eine Disruption erfährt. Und wie gesagt, das kulturelle Leben ist nochmal besonders unter die Räder gekommen, in diesem Ganzen, weil's einfach auch so gering geschätzt wird, ja? Autos werden vierundzwanzig sieben produziert
Aber der Rest darf irgendwie gar nicht und das, das kann man einfach nicht erwarten, dass sie sich nicht drauf vorbereiten
ist die Aufgabe der Politik, die Rahmenbedingungen dafür zu finden, dass diese Leute auch irgendwie ihre Zukunft planen dürfen. So.
Dass dann die Rahmenbedingungen auch.
Stehen, unter denen man diese Planung auch durchführen kann, wenn sie nicht komplett unrealistisch sind. Und das sind sie nicht, ja? Dieses Konzept im letzten Sommer.
Nichts wäre passiert auf der Fusion.
Nichts. Hätten wir die Chancen gehabt, dieselben Rahmenbedingungen bereitzustellen in diesem Sommer hätten wir gehabt.
Haben wir jetzt ausführlich schon drüber geredet, ist ein halbes Jahr generalstabsmäßig verkackt worden in diesem Land.
Aber dann will ich nicht sehen, wie sich irgendeiner aus dem politischen Betrieb beim Zeigefinger hinstellt und sagt.
Aber so geht's halt nicht, ihr könnt ja hier nicht feiern, wie ihr wollt. Wo kommen wir denn da hin? Jetzt ist immer Karfreitag, ja? Hier wird nicht getanzt.
Ja, ein ein Ding, was eben auch bei bei Lanz, die Melanie bringt man, glaube ich, hat sie das bemerkt, war ähm.
Dass das größte Problem eigentlich die Ziellosigkeit ist der Politik.
Man eben niemals formuliert hat, was man denn erreichen möchte, wo man denn irgendwie hin will, obwohl,
Ziel und der Weg dahin eigentlich auf der Hand liegen und zwar.
Der Grinch Moment wirklich, wie sie, wie sie wirklich in diese Runde geguckt hat und so und sie gefragt hat, was ist denn euer Ziel? Ihr müsst doch mal was was wollt ihr denn überhaupt.
Und alle guckten so völlig entsetzt, um man da hat so richtig gesehen, dass sie keins formulieren konnten. Keiner, keiner hat einen Plan, keiner, keiner will noch irgendwas. Alle wollen nur sich irgendwie dadurch wurschteln.
Das ist irgendwie weggeht, Augen zu und dass es halt weggeht. So.
Ja, alles mit Will Magic Lea Disapier.
Ja. Genau.
Magisches Denken. Das hat auch dieser dieses Quarksvideo, was ich vorhin erwähnt habe, ja. Das war sozusagen ihre Analyse. Dass das, was die Politik gerade macht, ist magisches Denken.
Magisches Denken, äh alternative Fakten aus alternativen Quellen ähm ja und äh ja.
Okay. Lass uns dich äh weiter darüber reden. Wir drehen uns auch ein wenig im äh Kreis und.
Auch mal die Sendung hier bald mal zu Ende kriegen. Gibt aber noch ein paar Dinge, äh die wir ansprechen sollten. Blicken wir doch mal auf die Welt der äh Impfstoff
Produktion, ich hatte es vorhin schon kurz angedeutet, war ja in den Nachrichten, dass das lang erwartete äh Biontechwerk in Marburg ähm
dass sein Betrieb schon im Februar aufgenommen hatte, hatten wir glaube ich hier auch schon erwähnt, aber jetzt sind eben die in den letzten vier, fünf, sechs Wochen,
produzierten Impfdosen auch tatsächlich freigegeben worden, das heißt, dass
ganze Werk ist jetzt offiziell zugelassen und abgenommen worden, keine Ahnung, was da im Detail für Prozesse stattfinden müssen, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn irgendjemand äh ein Impfstoffwerk herstellt, dass es dann schon eine gewisse Abnahme bedarf,
Das bedeutet, dass die jetzt dort produzierten Impfstoffe äh nach Belgien weitergeleitet werden dürfen, denn dort findet dann die Abfüllung statt
Aber der große Fortschritt bei diesem Werk ist wohl, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dass sie äh von den äh vier Schritten, die so insgesamt ähm da erforderlich sind, um
diese Impfstoffe zu produzieren, die wichtigen ersten drei genommen haben und der vierte ist dann eben diese äh Abfüllung und deswegen,
läuft's da jetzt schnell an und sie können auch größere Mengen produzieren.
Das ist äh gut für uns, weil damit kann Biotech vermutlich die Zusagen auch halten. Danach sah es eigentlich sowieso schon die ganze Zeit aus und das äh bestätigt sich jetzt. Insgesamt
äh ist, glaube ich, auch biontech etwas optimistischer
nochmal die zugesagten Lieferungen sogar nochmal ein paar Prozent zu erhöhen. Das hat einerseits was damit zu tun, dass eben diese sechste Dosis ja offiziell entnommen werden darf. Das ist ja schon ein bisschen länger so. Ähm ne, weil damit sind's
quasi derselbe Stoff auf einmal äh nochmal ähm zwanzig Prozent mehr und äh andererseits.
Konnten sie wohl auch den gesamten Prozess hier und da noch weiter optimieren und damit auf größere Mengen kommen.
Außerdem gibt's noch verschiedene andere gute Nachrichten von Bion Tich
denn äh diese Phase drei Trials, die ja zur äh Notfallzulassung.
Geführt haben oder zur vorläufigen Zulassung äh in Europa, also in USA und in,
UK, sind das ja irgendwie richtige Notfallzulassungen gewesen, da wurde es ja sehr schnell durchgewunken. Das war so ein bisschen auch High Risk, aber hat ja funktioniert
Und äh in Europa
sollte das ja nie getan werden, aber man hat sozusagen eine vorläufige Zulassung. Diese Phase drei Trials hatten dann sozusagen einen gewissen Freshhuld erreicht, also einen gewissen Schwellwert, eine Mindestanzahl an ähm,
Fällen zum Vergleich, sodass man eben sagen kann, okay, der Impfstoff funktioniert offenbar so und so gut. Aber.
Ähm abgesehen davon, dass er dann auch diese Phase vier eintritt, also die Beobachtung, der dann tatsächlich geimpften Personen
Läuft auch diese Phase drei noch eine Weile weiter, weil am Ende muss es ja auch eine finale Zulassung geben bei zumindest bei der FDA. Ich glaube, in Europa ist da jetzt nichts äh noch äh erforderlich deswegen. Aber diese Notfallzulassung,
Muss ja irgendwann auch mal überwunden werden. Und dazu haben sie jetzt neue äh Zahlen veröffentlicht
Das Ganze bezieht sich eben weiterhin auf sechsundvierzigtausend Teilnehmer
Da hatten sie irgendwie dann neunhundertsiebenundzwanzig Erkrankungsfälle, wovon achthundertfünfzig in die Placebo-Gruppe fielen siebenundsiebzig in diese Impfstoffgruppe, also damit
dann sozusagen diese Effizienz dann offiziell auf einundneunzig Komma drei Prozent
korrigiert worden, das entspricht glaube ich in etwa dem, was auch am Anfang da war. Interessant ist nur, dass es da unterschiedliche Zählweisen gibt, also die FDA und die CDC, also die eine C äh Arzneimittel und Impfstoffzulassungsbehörde, das andere ist die CDC, die halt diese
ähm Desaster Control macht. Die haben irgendwie unterschiedliche Kriterien dafür. Und nach FTA äh,
Kriterien.
Sind sozusagen alle schweren Fälle verhindert worden mit dem Impfstoff, bei der CDC, die irgendwie andere Grenzwerte hat, ist da theoretisch noch einer durchgegangen, also Schutz vor schweren Fällen liegt halt je nachdem wie man da glauben möchte bei dreiundneunzig Prozent oder bei hundert Prozent oder
Es gab einen Fall, der sozusagen noch mit reinzählt oder nicht. Das ist aber alles gar nicht so wichtig, worauf ich eigentlich hinausweile ist, dass man jetzt eben noch,
einen längeren Betrachtungszeitraum hat und man äh jetzt auch sieht, dass die hohe Schutzwirkung des Impfstoffs tatsächlich auch mindestens sechs Monate anhält.
Also längeren Zeitraum kann man jetzt einfach noch nicht feststellen, weil läuft ja alles noch nicht länger, aber das war ja immer so eine große Frage, okay impfen, ja, hält wunderbar, aber wie lange hält er denn
wunderbar und ganz offenbar hält er mindestens sechs Monate wunderbar. Was schon mal eine gute Nachricht ist.
Und es sind auf jeden Fall bemerkenswerte Zahlen, weil.
Du hast natürlich schon bei jedem Impfstoff äh einfach auch sogenannte Impf,
Versager äh äh dabei, wo die Impfung einfach nicht funktioniert, weil das Immunsystem geschädigt ist in der Regel oder aus,
anderen möglichen Gründen äh ja, funktioniert halt eine Impfung nicht bei jedem.
Wenn man das noch in Betracht äh zieht, äh, ja, ist das schon bemerkenswert gut, die Zahlen.
Außerdem ist reißen die guten Nachrichten reißen nicht ab, äh hat man jetzt auch ähm Kinder von zwölf bis fünfzehn betrachtet.
Und festgestellt, dass dort sogar der Impfschutz bei ganz klar bei hundert Prozent liegt. Also da sind einfach überhaupt gar keine Fälle aufgetreten,
Und äh sie sprechen sogar davon,
dass sie also eine sehr gute Verträglichkeit gesehen haben, dass die Kinder also überhaupt gar keine Probleme damit hatten und auch extrem
hohe Antikörperantworten produziert haben. Also offenbar funktioniert der Impfstoff nicht nur bei Kindern überhaupt.
Funktioniert offenbar bei Kindern sogar noch besser. Ich habe jetzt keine Information dadrüber, ob da die Dosierung angepasst wurde, ob da irgendwie weniger dosiert wurde.
Aber wenn sie gute Verträglichkeit assistieren, sondern äh scheint welche Dosis sie auch immer gewählt haben, die Richtige gewesen zu sein, da sie sowohl gute Ergebnisse erzielt, als auch eben keine Probleme erzeugt. Und jetzt starten auch die Tests mit Kindern.
Unter zwölf Jahren, also von ich glaube vor einem halben Jahr bis zwölf Jahre. Ja, sprich,
ist weiterhin eine Erfolgsstory, kann man nicht anders sagen und ähm würde ich nehmen, nur mal so nebenbei. Höre ich nehmen.
Ja, bei,
anderen Impfstoffen äh gibt's auch ähm ein paar Nachrichten, was auch so ein bisschen in die Diskussion kam, ist jetzt äh Sputnik V der russische Impfstoff.
Gab's einen interessanten äh ein interessantes Interview, ob äh beim Spiegel.
So ein bisschen ähm einem Impfstoffvermarkter von diesem Impfstoff geredet wurde, so ein bisschen darüber, wie wie denn das eigentlich so läuft und wie die das eigentlich so sehen,
Die Situation ist ja so, dass die Zulassung jetzt bei der EMA gestartet wurde, also dieses Rolling Review findet statt, hat man glaube ich letzte Woche auch drüber gesprochen und ähm
generell ja auch die Zahlen mittlerweile ganz gut aussehen, also das was quasi veröffentlicht wurde, ähm das lässt durchaus den,
Eindruck entstehen, dass auch der russische Impfstoff äh funktioniert
das ist ja der Impfstoff, der im Prinzip genauso nach oder nach demselben Prinzip funktioniert, wie der Astrazeniker-Impfstoff, also ein Viktor-Virus, man nimmt also einen anderen
Virus und setzt den quasi nur die Produktionsfabrik für das Bike-Protein des Saarskopf zwei Virus ein
vertraut aber auf den Virus mit seiner Einbruchstechnik in die menschliche Zelle, um das Material auch an der richtigen Stelle abzuwerfen
Und während Astra Senicke auf diesen Schimpansenvirus, also sie sind Schimpansen-Adänovirus gesetzt hat, sitzt äh sputnik auf den auf menschliche Varianten
AD fünf, AD sechsundzwanzig, also für jede Info auch noch ein anderer.
Und ja das ist so ein bisschen auch die Aussage, dass äh humane Adinovieren halt auch sehr bekannt sind,
Ja, also darüber weiß man einfach viel über die Verträglichkeit und äh die haben dann generell einfach auch bisher einen guten Treckrekord gehabt, sodass eben nicht davon auszugehen ist, dass es irgendwelche Probleme mit sich bringt,
weiß man natürlich auch erst am Ende alles so, ne? Problem ist nur, die EU hat noch kein Sputnik bestellt. Und es ist insofern sehr ungewöhnlich,
als das eigentlich jeder Impfstoff, der in Europa zugelassen wurde.
Zum Zeitpunkt, als diese Zulassung begann. Also zum Zeitpunkt, wo die EM EMA sich mit diesem Impfstoff beschäftigt hat, zu dem Zeitpunkt waren eigentlich die Kaufdeals schon.
Gemacht. Obwohl wir da spät dran waren,
Das ist offensichtlich bei Sputnik nicht der Fall. Es gibt also irgendeine Zurückhaltung bei der EU,
Und man kann jetzt drüber rätseln, was äh sozusagen da dahinter steckt. Was noch dazu kommt ist, dass äh die Russen auch gerne Sputnik V,
in Deutschland auch in anderen Ländern, in Europa produzieren lassen würde,
Das ist aber zum Beispiel in Deutschland nur möglich, wenn du auch eine eine Zulassung der EMA hast. Selbst wenn der Impfstoff für andere Länder produziert wird, also du kannst in Deutschland nur einen Impfstoff produzieren, der auch in Deutschland zugelassen ist,
Du kannst nicht in Deutschland einen Impfschoff machen, der nach Lateinamerika geht, auch wenn ihn in Deutschland nie einer sieht. Das ist interessant.
Na ja und auf jeden Fall in diesem Interview äh beklagt dieser Mensch äh ein Widerstand, der der Pharmabranche da stecke ich jetzt nicht äh so drin und der geht auch nochmal auf ein interessantes Detail ein, nämlich,
diese Benennung, ja das äh das hätten sie laut seiner Darstellung nicht so auf dem Zeiger gehabt, dass das im Westen nicht so gut ankommen würde.
Das war ja auch so ein bisschen unsere Reaktion, ich weiß nicht, ob's dir so ging, mir ging's auf jeden Fall so. Also diese Nachricht kam mit. Ja, wir haben zwar noch keine Phase drei Tests gemacht, aber wir haben hier total den geilen Impfstoff und wir sind jetzt mal die ersten und die Geilsten.
Ja und wir nennen den jetzt auch noch Sputnik, da dann dachten wir doch alle so, äh bitte.
War eine völlig überflüssige Politisierung dieses Impfstoffs.
Die dann natürlich nicht dazu beiträgt äh dass man den als seriös äh,
wahrnimmt oder als seriöser wahrnimmt, weil man das Gefühl hat, okay
das ist jetzt irgendwie auch mit Propaganda oder mit Politik verknüpft und wenn dem so ist, können wir ja gar nicht so richtig trauen äh den,
Angaben, die sie dazu machen, weil sie natürlich mögliche Probleme damit dann allein schon aus politischen Gründen verschleiern würden oder müssten, dass diese Unterstellung,
Schwingen da natürlich mit und die Namensgebung äh ja äh war da definitiv nicht die allerklügste.
Er sagte dem Interview,
Dass sie ihnen das erst später aufgefallen wäre und das war ja gar nicht so gemeint. Für sie würde halt äh Sputnik einfach für Zukunft und Fortschritt stehen und dass das sozusagen im Westen so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein schwieriges Thema ist, weil der
sozusagen so ein bisschen eben auch exemplarisch für den,
des Kommunismus über den Kapitalismus äh steht, so. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihnen das nicht schon mal jemand erzählt hat, dass es irgendwie äh so wahrgenommen werden könnte. Also, da steckst du jetzt nicht drin, dass dass,
jetzt einfach mal so stehen lassen.
Natürlich wollten die das der Welt und dem Westen irgendwie äh äh reinschmieren ähm so ähm.
Also unterstelle ich jetzt einfach und äh ja also bal,
Es ist schon ja, ich meine, was hat denn bitteschön jetzt ähm äh ja das Ganze mit Raumfahrt zu tun, außer äh dass es halt äh,
ein ein Kapitel im Kalten Krieg war im.
Teil des des Rüstungswettlaufs, der dann auch im Weltraum erstmal stattgefunden hat.
Ich kann ich kann nicht in die in die russische Seele blicken. Kann nur gut sein, dass wir jetzt irgendwie in Russen fragen, ähm sagen so, ja okay, hier sputig, was geht dir als erstes durch den Kopf, dass einfach dieser internationale Konflikt nicht so auf dem Zeiger ist.
Ja, die Russen machen sich glaube ich weniger einen Kopf um uns als äh wie um sich selbst so generell, also ich glaube nicht, dass die da jetzt äh sagen,
der der Blick so nach außen fokussiert ist, sondern mehr nach nach innen habe ich das Gefühl.
Das äh würde es ja bestätigen, was er gesagt hat.
Egal, also auf jeden Fall ähm ist noch unklar, ob Sputnik äh zu uns kommen wird. Sicherlich eine
eine Option, die man sich offen lassen halten muss, der Impfstoff wird ja schon in glaube fünfzig Ländern benutzt. Allerdings hat auch Russland echte Produktionsprobleme
Sie müssen ihnen zum Beispiel selber aus Korea teilweise importieren, weil sie einfach in äh ihrem eigenen Land nicht die entsprechenden Kapazitäten haben, hier wirklich groß zu produzieren. Und ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Grund,
gerne mit Deutschland zusammenarbeiten würden, weil es hier einfach verschiedene Standorte gibt, die da wohl mehr oder weniger schnell loslegen könnten, aber das hängt halt alles wiederum an dieser Zulassung und das äh scheint alles auch nochmal so ein merkwürdige
politische Geschichte zu sein, wo ich gar nicht weiter nachfragen will, was da die Ursache sein kann.
Also mein letzter Stand ist das immer noch niemand eine Zulassung beantragt hat.
Nein, der letzte Stand ist, dass dass äh die Ema, äh so ein Rolling-Review gemacht hat. Das heißt, sie nehmen jetzt die Ergebnisse äh mit rein.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen, es gibt jetzt noch keinen keinen finalen Termin, aber der Prozess ist gestartet.
Es gibt bloß eben noch überhaupt gar keine Verhandlungen der EU mit den Herstellern von Sputnik V, ob man das nicht vielleicht auch mal kaufen könnte, wenn's produziert wird oder vielleicht auch in Deutschland produzieren könnte, weil warum eigentlich auch nicht.
Spricht da irgendwas dagegen? Ich meine, das ist ein Impfstoff. Entweder funktioniert oder funktioniert nicht, wenn er funktioniert, wird man's sehen, wenn er zugelassen ist. Ich meine, er wird schon irgendwie überall verimpft, der wird schon funktionieren. Könnte man ja auch mal nehmen. Ist ja nicht so, dass wir jetzt genug Impfstoff hätten.
Oder dich der Rest der Welt noch welchen gebrauchen könnte.
Ja, also ich höre auch, dass es eben einen gewissen Impftourismus äh gibt nach Russland, auch gerade, weil man dort eben.
Am günstigsten äh an der Impfung kommen kann, hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal in der Sendung, wo, wo, also man halt viel Geld hat, kann man halt äh ja, nach Dubai oder.
Andere arabische Länder fahren, da gibt's dann für viel Geld aber in Moskau kann man halt.
Mit Flug äh und und Unterkunft und so kommt man wohl unter tausend Euro weg äh mit ja Impfung und ähm.
Und gehört, dass es einige Leute äh auch in Anspruch genommen haben.
Das ist eine ganz neue Vorstellung von All Inclusive, ne? Ja, Frühstück, Abendessen, Mittagessen.
Und Impfung in einem. Nachrichten gibt's auch noch von moderner.
Moderne hat nämlich angekündigt, dass sie äh ihre Patente auf den Nimpfstoff, die sie halten, das sind wohl so ein paar. Äh nicht ähm entforsten werden,
Während der Pandemie,
Das ist ein interessanter Move. Ich meine, wir hatten diese Debatte ja hier auch schon mal im Zusammenhang von entsprechenden Forderungen, die gestellt wurden, dass man doch jetzt bitte generell darauf drängen sollte, dass diese Patente ausgesetzt werden oder vielleicht sogar die Unternehmen dazu bringt, das selber zu machen
Hier hat es jetzt moderner angekündigt, dass sie das so halten wollen.
In der Pressemitteilung dazu ist ich's richtig gesehen habe, so ein bisschen davon die Rede, dass sie sagen okay äh jetzt erstmal keine Patentdurchsetzung und äh später könnt ihr das dann auch lizenzieren.
Ja, also da steht jetzt nichts von kostenlos lizenzieren oder so. Ähm ich deute das mal als.
Hier wird schon irgendwie ein Schritt gemacht, um vielleicht auch tatsächlich ähm zu befördern, dass Impfstoff schneller
umgesetzt wird. Wir hatten ja über die ganze Produktion und den Aufwand äh der erforderlich ist, um R und A Impfstoffe zu machen, schon gesprochen. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass man da mal eben so schnipst und dann hat man da wieder eine neue Produktionsstraße
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ähm könnte das hier entweder ein hilfreicher oder zumindest ein politischer Move sein, den moderner da macht.
Ja, also ich ich glaube das ist nicht viel mehr als einen.
PR Move. Ich habe meine Zweifel, dass irgendjemand.
Auf den Zug aufspringen wird. Ähm aber wir werden sehen. Meines Angebot ist da, aber so.
Sagen, die es erfordert ja dann erhebliche Investitionen. Äh.
Du das machen musst und äh ich meine entweder ich meine letztlich ist es halt ein.
Lizenzangebot mit einer nicht genau spezifizierten Lizenz freien Zeit ähm,
der Unterschied, also in der Praxis sie auch sagen können, so okay hier könnt ihr es günstig lizenzieren äh bei uns, das wäre deutlich,
solider als jetzt dieses Angebot, weil ehrlich, hm, wer würde jetzt äh schon einfach ohne.
Deren äh Know-How loslegen wollen und investieren und dann am Ende ja,
schlechte Karten bei Lizenzverhandlungen haben, weil dann hat's zu halt da dein Impfstoffwerk äh
auf irgendwie moderner Wachsinherstellung ausgerichtet ist und ja dann ja ne also hm,
klingt äußerlich gut, aber äh die Substanz kann ich nicht so richtig erkennen, aber es ist interessant, was sie äh äh trotzdem so.
Dann davon sich geben.
Gut, ich meine, im schlimmsten Fall ist es äh äh, dass sie sich jetzt erstmal politischen Druck von der Schulter nehmen, weil sie irgendwie äh.
Die Diskussion jetzt gerade echt nicht gebrauchen können und anderes zu tun haben. Dann gab's noch eine interessante Meldung von der WHO.
Die hat sich nämlich tatsächlich äh geäußert zu dieser ganzen Frage und das hatten wir ja neulich ja auch hier als dieser Hamburger äh,
Wissenschaftler von der Universität in Hamburg sich dazu äh geäußert hat mit diesem etwas unerquicklichen.
PayPal kann man dazu gar nicht sagen, Bericht, den er da aufgestellt hat
irgendwie alle möglichen Naziquellen zusammengefickt hat aus dem Internet und meint so, ja das das Virus kommt ja hier aus dem Labor in Wuhan. Das lässt ja nicht nach
Gibt auf jeden Fall bei der WHO auch eine Gruppe, die sich mit dieser Frage auseinandergesetzt hat. Das Ganze ist politisch natürlich auch sehr aufgeladen, gerade was so die Rolle für Chinas in der WHO betrifft und natürlich waren die vor Ort in Wuhan, aber dann mit Zugängen und so weiter.
Keine Ahnung. Ich stecke da nicht so richtig drin. Ich sage nur, was jetzt das Ergebnis war. Das Ergebnis ist, dass sie.
Als Ergebnis dieser Untersuchungs äh Kommission sagen, dass,
mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass eben durch äh.
Also dass der Ursprung des Virus in der Fledermaus liegt und die Übertragung durch einen Zwischenwurt als wahrscheinlich bis sehr wahrscheinlich angesehen wird.
Und konkret wird hier von Pangolinen, das sind so diese Schuppentiere, äh Katzen.
Oder Nerze? Die werden genannt,
nicht als eins von den Dreien ist es, sondern als Beispiel für Tierarten, die äh von denen man mittlerweile weiß
dass eben dieses Virus sehr gut weitergeben können. Naza hatten wir hier schon mit den Merzfarben. Gibt's ja jetzt auch die Impfstoffe dafür.
Katzen ist ja auch schon mehrfach nachgewiesen worden, ne? Die Tiger da im amerikanischen Zoo waren irgendwie infoziert und bei den Pangolinen ist es halt ähnlich
und äh ihre virologische Nachforschung, was auch immer, die da konkret getan haben, sagt halt, äh, das sei ihr wahrscheinlichstes Modell.
Und es sei auch ähm extrem unwahrscheinlich, dass es aus einem Labor.
Die ähm was man auch, was man auch noch dazu sehen muss, ist, sie sagen.
Keine direkte Übertragung durch die Fledermaus, das sagen sie deshalb, weil die evolutionären Unterschiede zu dem Virus, den sie aus den Fledermäusen kennen. Mehrere Jahrzehnte ausmache.
Das heißt, es kann laut dieser Darstellung sehr gut sein, dass das quasi.
Das ist von der Fledermaus mal auf ein anderes Tier übergegangen ist, aber das bei der angenommenen Evolutionsgeschwindigkeit, die das in so einer Tierpopulation dann haben,
kann, wie auch immer sie auf diese Zahlen gekommen sind, sie davon ausgehen bei.
Hat ja immer so gewisse Erwartungshaltung, wie, wie, wie schnell so Mutter, Muttationen stattfinden. Ähm,
Ja, das ist irgendwie Jahre und Jahrzehnte gedauert hat, bis das sozusagen wirklich in der Form war, in der es dann im wiederum von diesem Zwischenwirt auf den Menschen übergesprungen ist.
Ich kann dazu nur nochmal auf einen äh Podcast von mir verweisen, nämlich den letzten, den ich in der Folge äh im Podcast CAE rausgebracht habe. Da geht's nämlich um Fledermäuse. Weil ich im Fledermauszentrum
äh Schleswig-Holstein und äh habe mich mal mit dem Fledermaus-Experten unterhalten, unter anderem sprechen wir auch über diese ganze,
Virus äh Theorie, aber wir reden vor allem auch viel über Fledermäuse und das ist sowieso eine sehr unterhaltsame Sendung, kann ich euch empfehlen. CAEFM, Link findet ihr in den Shownotes.
Ja und dann gibt's weniger Kinder durch Corona Pavel.
Italien hat einen Rückgang der Geburtenrate durch Korona zweiundzwanzig Prozent, Frankreich, dreizehn Prozent, Spanien, dreiundzwanzig Prozent, USA, geschätzt, acht Prozent.
Bei uns.
Keine Zahlen, weiß ich nicht. Also nicht, dass es keine gibt, ich kenne sie nicht,
Ich hab hier ein paar Quellen äh vorgeworfen worden und war faul und hab's nicht weiter nachrecherchiert, aber das ist sozusagen das, jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen, warum
Oh, weil,
naheliegende Vermutung wäre erstmal gewesen, ja, alle hängen die ganze Zeit zu Hause rum, was haben sie besseres zu tun, als Kinder zu zeugen? Ja, dieser alte Mythos von der Strom ist ausgefallen, Geburten äh Explosion, neun Monate später
Das lässt sich hier nicht machen und meine Vermutung ist die.
Äh ungewisse Zeiten sind nicht gut für äh Familienplanung. Man hat das ja auch gesehen in.
Ostdeutschland nach der Wiedervereinigung ging ja für ein paar Jahre auch die Geburtenrate extrem zurück, weil die Leute einfach nicht wussten, was jetzt ist, ne. Man plant einfach äh seine Familie anders, wenn man's überhaupt plant.
Und also paar planen ja ne und Planung macht offensichtlich was aus, zumindest ein paar Prozent bis zu zweiundzwanzig Prozent vielleicht auch.
Man könnte natürlich auch sagen, dass andere Gelegenheiten, bei denen mal so eben so ein Kind entsteht, äh auch weggefallen sind. Das mag sicherlich auch noch so ein Faktor sein.
Mhm.
Ja, ich versuchte gerade äh zu gucken, ob ich was über die deutsche äh Situation rausfinden kann. Äh ich fürchte, dass.
Wird irgendwie noch ein bisschen.
Dauern, aber äh die Meldung dort ist keine die Meldung ist vom sechsundzwanzigsten März.
Keine spürbaren Auswirkungen des ersten Lokdowns auf die Geburtenzahl in Deutschland, also sprich.
Zeitraum von zweiundzwanzigsten März bis
Anfang Mai zwanzig zwanzig, ich meine, man darf nie vergessen, es dauert natürlich auch, bis sich so ein neun Monate, bis sich irgendwie der Anstieg bemerkbar macht. Das heißt,
Ja
wir wissen jetzt eigentlich nur sicher wie gesagt wie, wie sich die Leute bis bis Mai verhalten haben, was so jetzt äh Zeugung äh betrifft.
Und ja und da hat sich zumindest nichts verändert in Deutschland großartig wederauf noch unter.
Ja
Müssen wir nochmal im Blick behalten, wie sich das so äh entwickelt, vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu früh.
Frage mich halt auch gut, wie sie in Italien, Frankreich und Spanien und USA ähm.
Weiß ich nicht, ob die statistisch positive Schwangerschaftstests.
Erfassen, aber ähm ich glaube eher nicht, das heißt eigentlich können die ja auch nur maximal bis neun Monate zurückgucken jetzt mit ihren.
Zahlen, also wir sagen wie sich der die zweite und dritte und vierte Welle ausgewirkt haben wird man, wird man auch sehen, ähm aber ja.
Tendenziell vermutlich nicht so positiv.
Aber wie gesagt, bei uns zumindest äh ich meine, gut Geburtenrates schon niedrig genug, dass wir halt noch dramatisch, wenn's irgendwie noch weiter runtergehen würde.
So Pabel, jetzt muss man ja nochmal sagen, sagen wir mal so zwei, drei Branchen, von denen du denkst, dass sie äh von der Pandemie profitieren können.
Impfstoffhersteller.
Maskenhersteller.
Ja
Autohersteller.
Autohersteller, aha, interessante These.
Ja, weil ein Autohersteller ist es halt.
Nicht so schlimm gekommen, sondern du erinnerst dich ja an die Chipkrise, die da von der berichtet wurde, dass die Autohersteller.
Nicht genug Chips haben äh und.
Das Ding ist, äh dass sie halt äh als dann die Pandemie losbrach vor einem Jahr haben sie dann alle ihre Absatzerwartungen korrigiert und haben dann.
Eben keine Reservierung oder oder mehr Bestellungen von Chips gemacht, sondern halt äh ja eben weniger bestellt.
Und dann stellten aber viele Leute in der Pandemie fest, das ist irgendwie geiler ist mit dem Auto rumzufahren, als in der U-Bahn.
Im Bus oder im Zug,
Und äh ja, dann ging halt äh der, der Automobilabsatz entgegen den Erwartungen äh doch.
In die Höhe und.
Gleichzeitig saßen viele Leute im Homeoffice und merkten dass seit der zehn Jahre alte oder fünfzehn Jahre alte PC
es doch nicht ist beziehungsweise das, wenn man dann plötzlich die Geräte zwischen,
allen Familienmitgliedern in Dauernutzung im Prinzip, wenn ja äh Kinder halt äh,
für die Schule brauchen und man selbst fürs fürs fürs Homeoffice, ja,
hat dazu geführt, dass die PC-Industrie und zwar nicht nur jetzt ihr Laptop, sondern so richtig als schon klassische PCs. Zum ersten Mal seit
vielen vielen Jahren Wachstum vermeldet. Ich glaube zwanzig Prozent mehr PCs würden verkauft letzten Jahr, also.
PC-Industrie definitiv auch und.
Weil die dann wiederum diesen ungeahnten Zuwachs haben, die eben schneller die Kapazitäten dann verplanen. Normalerweise ist so, dass diese Chipfoundries zu.
Achtzig, neunzig Prozent ausgelastet sind, ständig und die ganzen zehn bis zwanzig Prozent, die freie Kapazitäten sind, werden dann üblicherweise benutzt, um dann Anpassungen vorzunehmen,
Planabweichungen und so. Als aber jetzt die Automobilindustrie,
alt feststellte, hm, wir brauchen jetzt doch mehr, stellten sie fest, halt, dass ja die ganzen PC-Hersteller schon die ganzen Kapazitäten, äh die da,
frei waren auf längere Zeit aufgekauft haben und die Chipfabriken laufen halt jetzt mit hundert Prozent, also da ist jetzt für sagen kurz entweder du hast schon bestellt
oder es wird halt halt problematisch so. Also Chiphersteller werden noch äh so ein.
Ja weitere weitere Branche die zumindest jetzt profitiert hat und möglicherweise noch weiter profitieren will. Ansonsten.
Weiß ich nicht, das sind diejenigen, die bei mir bisher so aufgefallen sind, aber ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Über diese Frage nachgedacht, aber du wirst uns jetzt bestimmt noch mehr erhellen, oder? Äh.
Äh zumindest habe ich noch ein interessantes Tit
bitte und zwar gibt es in Japan eine Branche, die tatsächlich äh in Zeiten der Panemie im Vergleich von äh Oktober zwanzig neunzehn, zu Oktober zwanzig zwanzig eine Umsatzsteigerung von zweihundertfünfundsiebzig Prozent verzeichnen konnte. Das hatte sich ziemlich dabei um die Hersteller von Herrenperücken.
Na japaner, also was hat man in der Pademie vor allem gemacht.
Man hat die ganze Zeit in Zoom-Konferenzen abgehangen.
Anderen Worten monatelang war man damit beschäftigt, die ganze Zeit auf seine anderen Kollegen zu starren.
Nun ist es natürlich in Japan so, dass quasi dein Status in der Gesellschaft sehr davon abhängt, wie sehr du dich da einfügst. Naja, das ist halt einfach so ein Prinzip,
Und während so äh der westliche Individualismus sich dann eher noch äh
darüber äh lustig gemacht hat oder dass es dann vielleicht auch noch zum Spaßprinzip erhoben hat, dass man dann sozusagen ohne Hose vor fünfhundert Videokamera äh sitzen, auch ansonsten die Frisur nicht so richtig äh passt und so eine Corona-Frisur irgendwie gewisser Hinsicht eingepreist ist und.
Genommen wird, funktioniert das so in Japan überhaupt nicht. Und da haben sich dann viele auch über ihr spinnendes Haar wahrscheinlich Gedanken gemacht und das hat dazu geführt, dass,
Herrenperückenhersteller einfach enormen Zulauf gehabt haben, weil halt viele äh
Meinung waren, sie müssten jetzt mal so ihre Haarpracht dann auch so auf den Standard heben, von dem sie der Meinung sind, dass der so gelten müsste.
Verstehe, hm.
Ja, jetzt sind wir zwanzig neunzehn in den Herparoten in äh Japan ins investiert.
Mhm.
Ach ja. Das sind so die Blüten, die so solche Zeiten dann irgendwie hervorbringen.
Dass es zum Ende kommt, wir müssen noch einen äh Termin verkünden, äh das wurde mir angetragen. Wir hatten hier schon mal dieses Sirokowit äh Projekt erwähnt, die sich ja.
Um Zerokovic, also ne, harter Lokdow und et cetera äh und alle damit verbundenen Maßnahmen,
die haben jetzt irgendwie am zehnten April einen Action Day eingerufen,
könnt ihr euch online irgendwie informieren, gibt ja auch noch die passende
dafür und da sind dann so verschiedene Ressourcen mit denen man sich dann an dem ganzen Spaß online beteiligen kann, was auch immer das dann bringen mag. Das wird sich dann äh zeigen, aber wer Lust hat, da mitzumachen
sei in den Shonots äh mit den entsprechenden Links ähm ausgestattet.
So und jetzt habe ich mein Pulver verschossen und ich würde sagen, wir bringen mal die Sendung langsam zu Ende.
Ja, wir haben auch irgendwie jetzt glaube ich schon zweieinhalb Stunden zusammen oder so.
Ja, das reicht.
Wir wollen noch äh noch irgendwie eine eine kurze Wrap-App Runde.
Na ja, wir haben ja nun äh schon viel über das geredet, was was wir denken, was so kommt, ne? Ähm und auch über das, was wir so gedacht haben.
Was passieren müsste und was wir so darüber denken, dass halt nichts passiert. Und das steht halt erstmal. Es zählen halt jetzt die Ergebnisse
denke wir werden nächste Woche mit einem Körper unsere Erwartung formulieren. Nächste Woche werden wir noch eine höhere Institanz haben,
Ostern wird hinter uns liegen. Wir werden schlechte Zahlen haben, weil die ganzen.
Gesundheitsämter erstmal Ostern wieder nachholen müssen. Das geht ja bis Montag der Spaß mindestens. Wenn's nicht sich noch länger weiterschleppt.
Ja, also frühestens irgendwie dann Mittwoch, Donnerstag, Freitag, nächster Woche äh wird's sich wahrscheinlich.
Beziehungsweise nicht normalisieren wird sich's erst in der Woche darauf, weil ich sage mal, ab ab Dienstag strömen dann wahrscheinlich erstmal wieder vermehrt Leute in Testzentren oder in in Arztpraxen, die.
Sich irgendwie nicht gut gefühlt haben, aber halt an Feiertagen jetzt nicht in die Notaufnahme wollten oder irgendwie zu viel Gewesen machen wollten.
Genau das Übliche, wie wir das Weihnachten auch schon hatten.
Ja und.
Genau, dann kommt dann also ein Berg beziehungsweise vorher werden wir wahrscheinlich eher aufgrund der Feiertage erstmal äh scheinbar niedrigere Zahlen sehen, die man die sind ja am Wochenende sowieso immer niedriger.
Aber natürlich, wenn da jetzt noch zwei noch Feiertage drumrum sind und so.
Außerdem wird sich sicherlich die Tatsache, dass jetzt im Moment keine Kinder in Schulen sind, äh wird sich auf jeden Fall auch positiv auswirken, weil äh das.
Gerade in vielen Bundesländern.
Die Gruppe ist mit der höchsten Insidenz, also das sofern äh ja die Schulschließung namens Ferien.
Helfen. Was im im Übrigen auch, ja, dieser dieser wirklich.
Dreiften und unverschämten und frechen Behauptung die Kinder würden ja Corona von zu Hause in die Schulen mitbringen und die Schulen wären ja gar kein Ansteckungsort, fuck you.
Ja? Echt? So, ja ähm.
Nee, muss muss hier auch mal äh gesagt werden. Ich meine, äh also wie klar muss man Szene noch servieren? Wir haben's am Anfang der Sendung gesehen. Das sind in meisten Ländern.
Äh Kinder und Jugendliche so.
Ja dort die dritte Welle ihren ihren Ausgangspunkt genommen hat und die seit die Schulen auf sind vorher die niedrigste Institz hatten und jetzt die höchste Institz von allen Altersgruppen
haben ja? So klar war's noch nie und es war im letzten Jahr auch nicht so schlimm, weil wir halt nicht dieses B eins eins sieben haben. So.
Ja? Aber also insofern, sorry für die für diese kurze äh ja äh Abweichung ähm.
Deswegen äh äh könnten wir halt jetzt tatsächlich erstmal niedrige R Werte, vielleicht sogar vereinzelt,
in Kombination mit eben Feiertagen dann niedrigere Zahlen sehen, was dann.
Wahrscheinlich dazu führen wird, dass die Dringlichkeit neuer Maßnahmen möglicherweise noch etwas verzögert wird, aber ähm so das dicke Ende bleibt jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich nicht,
das Wunder, also Wunder ist im Moment nicht sichtbar und auch wenn es in den nächsten Tagen nicht so krass abgeht äh oder weniger krass abgeht äh.
Dürfte das nicht die Entwarnung sein. Ja.
Was mit deinem magischen Denken, Pavel.
Ja und äh wie gesagt.
Können jetzt einfach sehr schön die Zahlen von vor einem Jahr und die aktuellen nebeneinander liegen und dann sehen, ob's den.
Dann jetzt einfach weggeht und.
Was man nicht vergessen darf, ich mein wir haben wir haben schon 'ne Menge Maßnahmen im Moment, man ist immer noch kein harter Lokdown, Prinzip kann man immer noch vierundzwanzig sieben sich mit.
So unter hier und da und da bestimmten Bedingungen aber tatsächlich.
Ja, Lokdown ist es nicht, was wir haben, aber trotzdem einen Maßnahmenbündel, was natürlich im Moment bereits äh schon den RWT drückt plus das.
Sicher schon die Beunruhigung über die dritte Welle jetzt auch bereit machen, wie wir aus vorherigen Wellen wissen, ist das auch immer ein starker,
Faktor, wenn die Leute das Gefühl haben, hm oder viele Leute das Gefühl haben.
Dass das jetzt draußen nicht so geil ist so und da sind viele Leute fangen dann einfach,
an sich selber zu schützen oder die eigenen Maßnahmen bisschen hochzudrehen, also früher die Maske
aufzusetzen und auch draußen viel länger aufzubehalten und solche Dinge ist es halt graduell.
Und ja das das zeigt auch auf jeden Fall 'ne Wirkung, insofern.
Ähm ja, hoffe ich, äh dass die Zahlen jetzt nicht so schnell steigen und sich die.
Noch eintreten sich nicht so drass, nicht so krass auswirken werden, aber eigentlich hätten wir äh seit.
Ja langem äh äh seit Wochen wieder äh eher im Loktown sein müssen oder äh zumindest ja
Ja, nicht anfangen dürfen über Lockerungen zu reden, bevor nicht die Institutionen im Keller gewesen wären und wir waren immer mal wieder, also was heißt relativ nah,
Sag mal vier bis sechs Wochen waren wir, waren wir tatsächlich entfernt von äh niedrigen Institzen.
Die auch Öffnung zugelassen hätten, aber wir haben uns entschieden, stattdessen jetzt die Corona-Saison zu verlängern, äh wegen ja großer,
großer Nachfrage oder ja gibt's Corona dieses Jahr halt länger als sonst.
Ja
Während eigentlich gefordert zu handeln, haben uns aber aktuell anders entschieden. Ähm,
Ja mal gucken was passiert. Es kann ja auch durchaus sein. Ich habe jetzt auch schon so erste Streikaufrufe äh gesehen. Ähm weiß ich noch nicht so richtig, ob das funktionieren wird.
Das Pendel schwingt gerade wieder in die andere Richtung und letztlich hat die Kanzlerin ja auch,
so mit ihrem Auftritt glaube ich schon was bewegt, also zumindest hm.
Denke ich, hat sie bei vielen Problembewusstsein zumindest geschaffen. Mh und äh ja,
und für ein bisschen mehr beunruhigung gesorgt und auch der eine oder andere ja politische
Führer, sage ich mal, ja, die ja auch alle so ein bisschen wankelmütig sind, pendelt jetzt wieder in die andere Richtung und ist jetzt gerade also ich,
ich sehe, dass die Koalition für.
Härtere Bekämpfungsmaßnahmen, gerade an Zulauf, Gewinde, Zulauf hat und äh wir werden sehen.
Ja, die Frage ist nur, wie lange dauert das halt, ne? Ich könnte mir halt entweder diese Streiksituation vorstellen, was mir auch vorstellen könnte, ist das so in der nächsten Woche, aber da wissen die Zahlen vielleicht noch nicht drücken, können auch einfach viele dann auch beschließen, ihre Kinder nicht mehr in die Schule zu schicken.
Das wäre ein sehr starkes Signal.
Ja, also ich würde meine Kinder definitiv nicht in die Schule äh schicken,
im Moment, weil äh ja das ist halt ein relativ guter Weg, sich die Krankheit nach Hause zu holen, wenn man sie noch nicht hatte bis.
Genau.
Ja, das äh könnte dann auch Druck erzeugen, ne? Ich meine äh Politik sagt, ja, hier Schulen öffnen, Schulen öffnen und dann geht keiner hin. Stell dir vor, ist Schule und keiner geht hin.
Sollten sie dann doch wieder aufmachen, äh sehe ich gerade in den Schulferien. Ähm wir haben die Situation, dass in Hessen und in Schleswig-Holstein die ähm.
Ferien eine Woche länger sind als in den anderen Bundesländern.
Also wenn wir dann immer noch im Nichtstun äh sind Ende April können wir da bestimmt interessant was aus den Institzen,
in den niedrigen Altersbereichen rauslesen, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt müsste sich das dann eigentlich auch schon längst rumgesprochen haben. Mal gucken,
Das ist sozusagen unser Ausblick. Alles nicht so rosig, Leute, aber bleibt äh wacker, ja? Kein Grund für Traurigkeit, wir kriegen das schon irgendwie alles gebacken. Die Frage ist nur wann.
Genau. Ja, früher oder später.
Meistens später, aber ja.
Dann wünschen wir euch noch ein schönes Wochenende oder wann auch immer ihr diese Sendung hört. Guckt nach bei UKW äh FM.
Ihr könnt es auch auf Twitter anquatschen, Pavel twittert fleißig, Pavel,
dreiundzwanzig ich äh auch als timpritlove. UKW hat auch einen Twitter-Account me_ukw
Und das sind alles so Orte, wo ihr Kommentare äh und Anmerkungen hinterlassen könnt, gerne aber auch in den Kommentaren im Blog auf VKW FM
und da findet ihr wie immer alle Links dazu
Ja und das Ganze wird dann noch gefolgt von unserer dienstäglichen Quatschrunde auf Clubhaus, ja,
nicht dran teilnehmen kann oder möchte, kein Problem
alles was relevant ist, landet sowieso am Ende immer in diesem Podcast, das ist die wichtigste äh Quelle. Für uns ist es aber ganz gut, da ins Gespräch zu kommen und wir werden oft auch auf neue Aspekte
hingewiesen oder sonst irgendwie korrigiert das äh ist immer ganz unterhaltsam. Ja,
Zum Schluss noch vielen Dank für alle, die auch die Mieterebene
finanziell unterstützen, um so Programme wie UKW möglich zu machen. Das war's aber jetzt auch schon von uns. Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut, bleibt gesund.